Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Dude,
it seemed like we just did this.
It does feel pretty recently.
A year ago.
I don't know.
It's already October.
I'm scared.
Let's just fuck and spark up a joint
launch.
One of them backwards.
Now.
One of these backwards.
These are so good.
Just smell it.
Just smell.
Whoa.
Yeah.
You know,
everyone was commenting on your blunt
rolling technique after the Elon Musk
thing.
Oh,
I don't roll them.
I know.
They were like,
and I knew that.
oh,
what does he.
He just,
he can barely roll a blunt.
I was like,
you're the professional in the world.
It's a pretty real good bond.
You can't read.
That.
Smells good.
It smells so good.
They taste good too.
There's a.
those are phenomenal.
The I,
I'm a blunt man.
Yeah,
I know.
It's probably bad for your lungs,
but there's something about the tobacco
gets you a little high up and then the
marijuana sort of like spreads you out
and it puts you in like a new dimension.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a good one.
I'm going to get blitz grieved after
Halloween.
Kids,
oh yeah.
Imagine how high you'll get to after 30
days.
Last year I did.
I did comedy.
I had no idea what I was talking about
while I was on stage.
I was like,
oh my God,
this 400 people in this room know what
I'm saying.
I always thought of bringing in all my
marijuana and booze in here.
Like,
like why like it?
Like in the old West when you have to
turn in your guns and just dumping them
on the table because I have so much
marijuana.
It's ridiculous.
I know.
It's crazy.
I keep a stack of whiskey over there and
then we've got another cabinet full in
the back.
Yeah,
you could get fucked up hard for you
here in this place.
We're going to ripped on the back.
Remember when we did the podcast on the
day back.
Those were,
those were fun shit.
Those clients so much more fun when he's
high and grumpy when he's sober.
I such a grouchy dog,
like legit,
angry,
like he could joke around about anything
when he's high,
when he smokes weed,
but then when he's not smoking weed,
you're like,
wait,
wait.
Are you fucking serious?
He gets upset.
Do you remember when you texted the
three of us?
Who are you?
I don't think you're doing the right
classes.
Do you remember?
You think you're going to have to do
them again?
Joking.
I love you.
He called you.
He called you upset.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
he was upset.
I don't remember if we texted or called,
but I go,
I love you.
I'm just joking.
I'm sure you do.
The one thing about Arias,
this is one thing that you could say
after all the welding talking on the
nonsense.
Ari has rock solid ethics off.
Yes,
he does.
Like if Ari says going to do something,
he does it like so if I'm fucking with
him and saying I don't think you're
doing it like I don't really mean.
Right,
right.
You're just kind of,
you're poking at them.
Right?
So if you're out there already and you
hear this molly fucking around,
I know you're doing it.
He can talk to you for the next 30 days.
Dangerous.
He came back,
he came to our class for that last one.
He was so much easier than most clubs
can believe.
You questioned how hard my class one we
didn't.
Encino.
Yes.
He was like,
this is so easy compared to what I've
been doing in New York.
Like it's all easy.
If you go easy,
I guess it's all how you do it.
If you.
If you do hot yoga and you go 100
percent every pose.
Yeah.
It's fucking hard to the matter who's
teaching?
Yeah,
it's hard.
But there's this guy that I go to a
hundred percent.
I have a drinking problem,
legit drinking water.
There's this guy that I go to yoga with
a who is a.
he's.
It seems like he just doesn't ever go
100 percent.
He started just kinda like,
you know,
you put your arms above your head.
He always does this.
He's never doing this research.
Fully stretched to extend his palms net
connected.
When you do that,
it's hard,
right?
If you just kind of half ass every pose
and do this.
Yeah,
you can get through a 90 minute class.
You're not doing the same thing as if
you do.
If you do any of you ever go to like a
group training class somewhere you can
see people and there's like a 63 year
old lady who's doing a with.
She's on her knees.
She was like,
this is hard,
and talking at a normal rate,
you're like,
you're not.
You're not doing it.
Yeah.
I got in trouble with my crossfit class
because I was just getting pissed.
I was throwing up everyday.
I was throwing up every single day.
I was also drinking a coffee right
before it started,
so it's throwing up coffee every single
day and one day I just snapped.
I go,
Hey,
the black guy's not doing his burpees.
The black guy.
That's what they said,
Joe.
That's what they said.
We don't talk like that.
It's got a name.
I go in,
I don't know it,
but I'm pointing to him.
He's not doing his burpees and then.
And then the joke I made out of it was,
hey,
a Wendell,
the gay guy says I can't call you the
black guy but you're not doing.
You're throwing it back to a cross fit.
I liked the idea that we're doing this
in general heart rate sense because you
can sprinkle it in.
I want to go to a spin class.
And by the way that is how,
if you want to like get a real bump in
those points,
it's about a bumping heart like
sustained accelerated heart rate.
So a spin class is gonna get you a
bunch.
You know what I mean?
It's not like Joe,
I don't know if you know that he's like
a way better athlete than you,
but it doesn't mean that we put pin in
that.
It doesn't mean the month to find me
that he'll automatically beat us because
he's in better physical condition.
You can actually beat them if you're
going to push it all the time.
What is it in your brain that makes you
do that?
Because we just looked at your map and
you burned a thousand calories.
Is there some sort of.
I talked to Pat McAfee one time,
he said it's about exclusivity.
It's about rape and murder.
My head's filled with it.
Stopping rapists and stop and murderers
and killing child molesters.
That's where.
Think about killing bad people when you
work out.
That's what I do.
When I get tired,
I get tired.
I think about like saving someone I care
about.
I think about stopping someone is trying
to murder someone I love.
That's what I think
about.
I love your face.
I'm not kidding.
I think about my second wife.
I think about protecting people I care
about.
Can you tell me one time you'll.
If it's hard,
you'll go a pretending someone is trying
to kill me.
Yeah.
So you're like pretending.
I really don't have words for that.
That's what you gotta do.
Cause that's,
that's what if you think about worst
case scenario,
you're tired and someone's trying to
kill someone you care about and you
don't have enough energy to stop them.
But do you think you learned that switch
in?
Like a type one is not talking window a
crow a learned from martial arts?
For sure.
Yeah.
Yeah,
sure,
yeah,
because that's the scariest place you
could ever be.
Like the scariest place that you could
be is life and death.
So like just putting yourself in.
Oh,
just want to lose weight.
Okay,
good.
Yeah,
that's good.
But that's not.
You're not going to save yourself like
you got.
You got to put yourself in like
animalistic fury.
That's how you gotta you gotta put
yourself,
you gotta to put yourself in this state
of just 100 percent effort.
I was pegged at 180 177 beats per minute
for the last 35,
35 minutes.
That's really,
it's got to do it.
See that David Goggins guy had gotten my
head with a.
just embrace the suck.
Yeah,
I can.
I can get there where I go and just
like,
like during the marathon I just go,
this is where I'm going to be for the
next five and a half hours.
This is where I'm at and is what I'm
doing and I can,
I can wrap my head around that.
I don't know if I can wrap my head
around like I don't know,
the explosive activity of it and going
like,
I'm going to save my family and then
getting,
but that might not work for you,
but there still could be a different
tactic that works for you.
You know what I mean?
Even like bat going that fucking hard to
where your body is completely giving
out.
There's part of me that goes,
hey man,
what are we doing here?
You know,
like when I'm working out,
I go,
it's really fucking hard.
Well,
you definitely have to protect your
health,
right?
Like the last you want to be doing this
and having a heart attack.
That's my.
That's always my fear is I go,
easy buddy.
Easy buddy is a good way to look at it,
but I've been doing that kind of working
out forever.
That's how it worked out.
Yeah,
that's.
You've always were crazy.
Yeah,
I go crazy.
Have you ever thought about someone who
like really disrespected you right
before you lift?
You know what I mean?
Like that's all that happens online.
You can't read that Shit because I've
gone to like a moment where you're like,
I wish I would have cracked that dude in
the face.
And then right before,
right before I said no,
I have not,
and I know I'm definitely know what I
want.
I know who I'm thinking about.
I'm going to try it.
All right.
Don't say any names.
What does he rhyme with in order to like
egg
to really get yourself into that place?
You know,
you don't have to think about something
that's terrifying and negative,
but to me that's like,
that's the ultimate position that where
you're going to need energy.
This is so silly.
That one.
The best shape I've ever been in is when
I met my wife.
I was 186 pounds.
I look at Jamie type in skinny burt.
I've almost had a six pack repack and I
had like side muscle,
a little little oblique.
I'm going for that this year.
This month I'm going to.
I'm going hard.
This month I've,
I've got,
I said to Jamie,
I made a deal with myself every day I'm
going to do air squats and 50 pushups.
I was going to do 100 look at skinny
burt posing,
but you are a fucking stud.
There was when I was in spin class.
Look how skinny her face is.
Well,
your sphere face was super skinny after
last year.
Sober October.
That photo that you posted that you sent
to us skinny face.
I'm going back.
I'm going hard this month.
I really am.
And I'm gonna.
Enjoy it.
Last month,
I think last time I did it was out of
spite.
I wanted to prove to everyone I could
stop drinking.
This month I'm going into it having not
drank probably a third as much as last
year,
meaning like I've drank three quarters
as much.
Does that make sense?
And so,
um,
but when I was in spend cost,
we had bob from the biggest loser was
our spin class teacher crunch.
This is Bob the coach from the biggest
loser contest.
And I never watched that show.
He was,
he was amazing.
His inspiration was so connect key
connected to me so quickly.
One time,
it's right before Thanksgiving and I'm
looking good.
I'm going to go to a wedding,
my buddy's wedding and I'm on on the
bike,
and he goes,
all right,
everyone out of the saddle is going to
be on the saddles for two minutes and
I'm like,
fuck this,
and then he says,
you're going,
whoa.
I felt like he was talking to me.
He goes,
you're going home for thanksgiving.
You're going to see all the people in
high school,
all the people that didn't want to have
sex with you.
Do you want them to want to have sex
with you this weekend?
And I was like,
yeah.
He goes,
that stay out of that fucking saddle
standard,
that saddle and earn your Thanksgiving
dinner and go out to bars the night
before and say,
I won't fuck you on better than you and
I'm just going to want them to fuck me.
I want them to fuck me.
I am that bombs.
I think with the heart and the paint
that connected with me,
so that vanity of like,
I want people to want me.
Isn't that funny,
man?
That bike motivated so many comedians.
Oh,
you know,
just being a loser in high school and
I'll show you guys.
I'll show you.
There's people that take them,
that takes them straight to their
deathbed.
They're still like,
yeah,
fucking Sarah is seventh grade.
This is for her.
Yeah.
My motivation is I think of getting to
the bottom of it is I want people to
like me because I know.
I know,
but I think it's on.
I do that in an unhealthy way.
I think I was pretty good speaking with.
Thank you.
You to liking my special is the best
compliments I've gotten.
You worked hard at it.
Thank you very much.
Everyone has secrets.
I mean streaming right now,
but Joe Rogan special drops tomorrow,
tonight,
tonight at midnight.
I saw that dude that that trailer is one
of the best trailers I've seen for a
special in a long time.
I worked hard at it.
I hope people like it.
Some people are gonna hate it,
but that's normal.
I worked at it as hard as anything I've
ever worked on ever.
For sure.
This our.
Yeah.
I fucking went hard on this one.
Good feeling to go to get done with
something.
I did the best I could do.
I did the best I could do for sure 100
percent.
I couldn't have done any better because
if I did any more.
The only thing that you could say is
maybe a little more time like maybe a
month or two more time on some of the
bits like,
but you never know when that is,
you know,
it's like there's a,
there's a,
there's a sort of like a period where
they're developing and then they mature
and then they're solid and then you
never know like are they done or zero
like one more tagline that I'm missing
here because you know how like it's
always the case you film and then right
after you're done you have a brand new
tagline that makes the bit.
It's like the next Saturday that mother
Fucker,
but next week I wrote that.
Did that special the next week I'm in,
I'm in Michigan doing some theater and
uh,
I have that Alexa bit about.
I'm fucking Alexa talking back,
talk to Alexa.
Like I talked to women in whatever the
bid is and the next week I write the bit
we set a fleshlight attachment for
Lexus.
Are you shut up the way I want to.
Fuck God damn it.
Where the fuck was that?
God Damn it.
Mind doesn't open up.
Your mind isn't open up all the way
until it's like,
it doesn't have any pressure.
The pressure's gone and then you're
like,
oh,
I can take it here.
I can take it there.
And you're like,
I wish I could think like this before I
record.
But you can't.
You know what's interesting is that
we've talked about this the after the
specials over,
like I don't have any material and I
don't have anything to think about.
But you always find it like overtime and
then before you know,
like,
wow,
I got to do our.
Yeah,
it happens.
It happens and it happens quicker the
more you've done it.
Yeah.
Because you know you can do it.
That's one of the sad things about these
guys.
Like I was talking to a guy the other
day,
like how long you been doing comedy?
And he's like seven years.
I go,
how much time do you have?
He's like 20 minutes.
Like,
oh,
that's fucking ruthlessly unacceptable.
It's terrible.
I go,
you are lazy when you've been doing
comedy for seven years,
you have 20 minutes and out of those 20
minutes 10 you should throw away.
Right?
That's crazy.
But that's what happened.
But they're not doing it enough.
You're not doing it enough.
They don't get enough sets in this,
you know,
it's hard.
You do an open mics and when you're
doing open mics,
everyone's sucks.
So you look like a hero if you have
anything that's remotely humorous,
but then you try that remotely humorous
stuff and you do it on at the Ice House
and people like,
yeah,
go on.
Between you and you and you know you do
this bullshit.
They're used to doing an open mic night
and people just not having it.
So a real sets are so different than if
you don't,
if you don't get in front of real crowds
and it's not,
you know,
it's not entirely up to you.
Obviously when you're starting out,
it's hard to get.
What do you mean?
Real crowds?
Like a real show.
A professional.
Oh,
like those shows an open mic,
you know?
That's why it's invaluable.
Like even if you give somebody an
opportunity to come on your show for
them,
like a,
an up and comer,
because they don't normally have real
audiences perform in front of giant for
them.
It's a wake up call.
Oh yeah.
Then they're like,
Holy Shit,
this is a real show.
People have expectations and they pay
money.
When you go to one of those open mic
nights,
people are just drunk and everyone's
terrible.
So you're just laughing at basically
anything you can kill,
but how bad they are.
People are just like slamming,
made almost career out of that.
Yeah.
Peter Chen,
who was a guy who is so bad.
I,
Chris Mcguire was auditioning for Mitzi
and Peter.
Mitzi thought it was funny because Mitzi
was so hilarious.
She thought it was funny that one of the
worst comics in La don't pull his
picture up,
was hosting the open mic night.
Really?
Yeah.
She thought it was funny and.
But I knew that mcguire was going to
have to audition for Mitzi,
so I said fuck that.
So I called up the store.
I said,
I'm hosting.
I'll host the open Mike Nights Jenelle
styles to the open mic night,
just just to keep him from hosting it.
That's great.
So you did that like as a save for your
buddy?
Yeah,
yeah,
because I knew he was gonna you know,
this would be too much to address and
you have three minutes.
That'd be too much.
Too much chaos to address.
I hosted a show as a favor one time and
ended up snapping on a lady in the
yachting and ruined the show and they
were like,
thanks.
Why did you a dude?
Because I arrived,
it was a showcase for Montreal and I
arrived at the show before it.
Right.
So there's like a 7:00
thing and then the 9:00
showcase and they asked me to to host it
and the and a lady at the 7:00
show at the earlier show is in like the
front row just yelling out drunk.
And she's older and she's like,
yeah,
like tagging every comics thing,
commenting on it.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I'm just so irritated.
I'm like,
well at least you know,
the show's almost over.
So the show ends,
you know,
people leave,
we're getting ready to our second show.
I look,
she stayed in her seat and I was like,
you gotta be kidding me.
So second show starts and I'm already,
you're primed.
You know,
like if you watch something that gets
you agitated and then you're like,
yeah,
you're overreacting because you're like,
you're primed for it.
So like it started and it was like I
said like my first joke and she said,
I go,
you fucking cunt.
Shut up.
So people in the audience like don't
talk to her like that.
And I'm like,
you don't know what she's doing.
So.
And then it just went really like given
up for this guy wants to go to Montreal.
It was terrible.
Oh No.
But then she ended up leaving.
Her friend came back in and while I'm
onstage goes,
did you call her a cunt?
Like in the show?
And I go,
yeah,
she goes,
that's my friend.
And I go within your control.
She leaves
and her son comes back,
her son comes home to me,
talk to you for a second.
And I was like,
alright.
And it looks serious too.
And he was like,
you call my mom a cunt when I go,
which one is she?
This lady over here.
So I go outside and I talked to
basically the lady who was the friend,
should I go?
She goes,
what is going on?
What go?
Your friend has been disrupting,
yelling out people,
drunk,
belligerent.
She goes,
you call her this,
you call me that.
And I go,
all right,
well I'm sorry I called you that,
but I'm not sorry.
I called your friend that she is what
she is.
And she's like,
you can be a nice person.
I see it in you.
I was like,
yeah,
I go get your friend out of here.
No one wants her here.
Okay.
And she was like,
okay.
And then her son was like,
thank you.
That was very disrespectful to my mother
and I was like,
okay man,
we're good.
I got to go back and host this disaster
that.
Okay.
Oh,
it was such a train wreck.
Well,
some people just think that if you're
saying something they disagree with,
they don't think that they need to just
like wait it out.
They think they can stop you in the
middle.
For me in particular,
a lot of my bits start off one way.
Like they look like they're going to be
way more outrageous than they are and
then I turn them around.
Sure.
But when I'm starting it off and then
you,
you just attack,
like,
like you're fucking up the bit,
you know,
you don't even understand what I'm
doing.
It's the whole thing about freedom of
speech in a weird way.
I had a joke about pedophilia and I just
started it.
And the woman,
this woman who was a fan of mine and
everything,
she just goes,
no stop.
And then now it looks like I'm probing
Ophelia.
I haven't gotten to the fucking
punchline.
Just looks like I'm in the fucking kids
because they will a lot to finish it.
No,
those people shouldn't be allowed at
shows because they're not even letting.
They're not even letting the art form
take place.
You can't.
You crafted something.
You don't let it play out.
You can't do that.
I mean you just,
they should just kick you out.
You just like,
you're fucking up the whole experience
for the whole crowd because like a guy
like Brian holtzman would literally
never be able to perform if the audience
is filled with people like that.
So people like you and I who enjoyed
them,
we would never be able to see him
because his whole act is saying
outrageous shit like that.
That absolutely he doesn't really mean.
Right?
But the funny thing is the twists and
the turns,
right?
And you to laugh at.
The other funny thing is,
is that he supposed to act like he does
mean it.
That's what's fun like that.
People are like,
always like,
you know,
they get super upset about this thing
and it's like he said this and they're
like,
yeah,
but don't you get that?
It's,
it's the performance.
I used to have this joke about the
second coming project.
Do you know what the second coming
project is?
When they first started fucking around
with genes and cloning,
they um,
there was a group of radical Christians
that had this idea.
I think it might've,
it might've been bullshit eventually,
but what their idea was they were going
to take some genetic material from the
shroud of Turin and they were going to
clone Jesus.
And so my bit was,
what if you clone Jesus and it doesn't
come out good.
Like,
you know,
they had to do Dolly the sheep like 30
times until they got it right.
Like what if,
what if you would,
if you cloned Jesus and he comes back
handicapped and I had this whole fucked
up thing about them following around
this handicap Jesus.
Instead of turning water into wine,
it turns like dog shit into the cookies.
And so this fucking lady,
this lady goes next subject and she's
sitting in the,
in the,
in the front row.
So I did the bit to her.
I looked her in the eyes and I kept
doing it,
you know,
by the power of Christ compel you and
doing it was a horrible pit,
you know,
it's like we're talking like 1998 or
some shit like that.
Right?
So it was clunky anyway.
But uh,
she's literally saying next subject,
which is,
I'm never gonna Never gonna listen to
you.
Like what?
That's like when you tell someone,
shut the fuck up.
Why would they shut the fuck up?
Nobody that doesn't work.
Nobody.
You want them to shut the fuck up.
But you have no understanding of the
power of persuasion or the fact that
other people aren't you.
Like you're not in control of other
people.
So if you tell someone,
shut the fuck up,
like,
that doesn't work.
This is just a poor way of you
understand,
you don't understand human beings like
you haven't thought this through.
You just know what you want your selfish
little head.
And so you say it to them,
this is how most arguments in most
fights get started because people don't
take into consideration at all the fact
that they're communicating with another
human being has their own set of
emotions,
their own life,
their own problems,
their own ego.
It's true.
There's a sure fire away any comedy show
to hear more of the same topic because
they'd be like,
next,
next subject.
Yeah.
That's a.
and that's what I.
I almost sometimes I preface it where I
go,
hey,
you got like if you don't like what I'm
about to say because I have a couple of
things now that are a little too far.
I could just talk to me after the show.
Don't,
don't even do that.
Just don't interrupt things.
I've got 500 people change my mind on
it.
Like I had a bit that worked on the buy
podcast very well.
And then I've tried it in the club and
this black chick came up to me and she's
like,
it's a really fucked up joke that was
like really super racist or something.
Was it super,
super racist?
Like the black guy at crossfit racist or
I think it might've been worse.
Really.
I don't know.
It didn't bother me.
But by the black chick in DC was like,
I love the show all of it.
I just think this is a year ago and I
was like,
a part of me is like a.
is it a bit that's in the special then?
No,
no,
no.
And so I,
and,
and it's,
it's like it's all,
it's almost like I didn't want to,
I wanted to tell it but I could figure
it out to work it out,
but I didn't wanna have to deal with all
the fucking steps,
all the steps.
And I was like,
I'm like,
I'm not going to die on the hill right
when I don't,
I don't really talk about race much in
my act.
So I'm like,
I don't really,
I'm not going to die on that hill for
that bit to do with a bit like that.
You gotta look at it as if you're
someone trying to deconstruct it.
Like you're someone who's trying to
attack that bit.
See for me a bit works best the very
first time I do it and then and then
every,
every work in bid I do around that to
like take it apart and figure out
another way to approach it.
That's where I start fucking it up.
It's like the first time I say it I go,
Ooh,
let's hope we can find that again.
That's I'm the polar opposite.
Oh No.
Occasionally I'll say something good the
first time,
but most of the time when I say
something that seems like a sprout or a
seed and then I'm like,
okay,
but how much time do you spend listening
to recordings?
A lot.
Now I look back to that last special.
I did it obsessive Lee and then I got
into it.
I got into recording and now what I do
is I will bid out if I don't have video
like that video because I think the
video aspect really lets me know why
things were like I this bit where I,
my I do my eyes a little different and
it was killing and I saw it on video and
Oh,
I gotta make sure to do that.
But um,
I,
for me it's like I,
it's almost like I'm always trying to
chase to get back to that first time I
told it that feeling.
Yeah.
I like to clip it out and then put
chunks of like,
all right,
here's where the starbucks bid is,
here's this is.
And then look at the different ones and
go,
oh,
why did that work better than this one?
But um,
but I'm also,
I've gotten really into editing videos
and stuff so it's a lot easier for me
than it was when I first started.
Now I'm just like,
oh,
real quick,
sync up audio and [inaudible].
I'll do audio and video,
different tracks.
Sync them up and then just clip them
out,
put them in folders.
Audio and video.
What do you mean?
What I do?
I got a little nerdy about it.
I take a h,
four,
six and eight.
Is that an audio recorder?
It's A.
It's a zoom recording.
Zoom h were six and then I'll take my
camera,
put it in the back if I can or I'll have
the club run,
run video,
but I'd like to sync up clean audio and
clean video.
That way if I do have something fun,
like Hannibal got on stage with me the
other night and I was like,
oh cool.
I got all this shit that's.
I could definitely put online if I'm
going to want to do that.
The Hannibal,
I'd have to run it by him first,
but I got real clean audio of it.
Oh that's interesting.
So you are doing it through the
soundboard?
No,
I do it through the h four slash six is
like the best and I have a basically a
surround sound mic on that.
Which ones are called the gun?
What?
H four slash six.
It's bigger than a zoom h four slash
six.
Right.
Am I right on that or is it just the
eight?
Six?
I would say the h six.
It's a six.
Eight,
six.
The other ones,
the h four n zoom,
zoom h six o them.
Yeah.
Audio recorder and it was big.
Is that thing?
It's about the size of.
It's about the size of this box,
but they make a zoo,
it looks like.
Yeah.
They make a zoom that's smaller that I
take with me now.
That fits in my pocket,
like the size of a lighter.
That's really great.
Yeah.
Pull that up.
Let me see what that looks like.
What I like about doing it on my phone
though is that I have them always with
me all the time and then I sync it up in
my car on the way to the Gig.
That's what I did the other night to
listen on the way there on the way out.
You go like that because I liked the.
I liked the puzzle solving aspect of
putting together sets.
You know what I mean?
When you go like a man,
like why does this,
when I do it fourth it kills,
but if I do it fifth,
it's garbage.
You know,
like you try to like figure it out.
Well maybe this needs to be punched up.
Maybe they should move here.
I liked doing that.
I like figuring that out.
Yeah.
And there's always those mystery
punchlines that you didn't think were
going to be a punchline and crushes.
Sure.
You know,
like what the fuck is,
what are you laughing at?
I don't get it.
Like what happened there
due to the time that you guys were in
the back of the room and I said I used
to think and Helen Keller the same
person and I didn't think that was funny
at all.
And you're like please don't do that a
bit.
And I was like,
no,
that was at a stand up on the spot,
on the spot.
I send them all the spots of the most
useful thing.
Yeah.
Super.
Okay.
So which one is,
you've got the h six.
I've got the H,
four n and then the h one n is the one
that got that take with me.
The h six is the larger one.
That's like a Taser looking thing and
then which is the one you take with you
the one.
And that's really little.
What's the comparison in the sound
between the h one,
N and h six.
A big jump in my opinion.
Yeah.
Jamie should be the same.
How?
So?
Uh,
I would,
it would be,
it should be the same microphones.
Uh,
the age six is just going to lie to do
six tracks.
That's what the six is logistics inputs.
This was probably just one track or
maybe it's too specific for this left
and right.
That's why there's two microphones.
Oh,
interesting.
That was a great mind.
I take that with me and you,
it shows you how much time you have.
You put a 64 gigabyte,
a mini SD card in and you get like 118
hours of recording.
How's the.
So if you do,
I go through batteries pretty quick,
but if you use lithium batteries,
it's not that bad.
So you do mini
sd card,
you could take that mini SD card and put
it if you have a phone.
Like I just got an android phone,
I got this,
a galaxy note nine and it has a,
it takes up to one terabyte of storage
shit.
Look at the stars.
Is that new?
But it takes an SD card.
Yeah.
Shut the fuck up.
It takes an SD card.
It takes up to one terabyte of storage.
Um,
it's fucking phenomenal.
Just phenomenal.
They used to be that they were like way
inferior to iphones.
It's not the case anymore.
In fact,
I think like,
look how big that screen is.
Yeah,
that's great.
Cup.
Ready?
Ready.
Who makes that a Samsung?
Let's see.
Um,
the,
the fingerprint reader is fucking
instant.
And it as a pen we could write on the
lock screen.
So on the lock screen you can take notes
and write on the screen.
I haven't written in my job fully and
forever.
I feel like.
Whoa.
You sure can.
And then you save those two you notes.
But yeah,
that's really cool.
And then this also works as a remote
control.
So if you're playing music,
if you play music on this thing while
you're playing music,
this will start and stop your music.
It's fucking funny.
I'm just going to stomp out your iphone
right now.
I don't know man.
I'm trying to figure out what to do.
I've always had that same phone.
No,
but the other thing about the new iphone
that Jamie was telling me is that you
can um,
you can have two different phone
numbers.
Were you telling me that?
No,
Brian was,
you could have two different phone
numbers and then one.
Yeah,
you can tell you what it tastes like a
second card.
So say like if you have a business line
and online,
right?
Then he'd take that Sim card out for the
business line or you disabled the
business line and you're like fuck you.
So say like if you have a phone that
only like your best friends your wife
have.
And then the next is like agents,
that other bullshit.
Yeah.
But you just set up a whole decoy number
for like people.
You don't want to have your number,
that's good.
But you can also do something like that
with,
um,
what is that thing?
Um,
here's a
google voice,
right?
Doesn't google voice have some shit like
that.
You can have a separate,
that's that.
You can have that rerouted to your phone
number and have like a business line
kind of thing.
We'll look at this.
This thing works as remote control.
So check this out.
I'll crank it up.
You take pictures with it too,
right?
Yep.
Got It.
So you're using that.
Can Watch it.
See that?
Oppress it.
Yeah.
Box Cutter.
Patsy,
come on.
How many of those pens do you get?
Like 10.
No sticks.
Right in your book.
Fits in there.
Bank.
That's perfect at charges.
It's Bluetooth.
Nice.
Syncs up to your phone.
Maybe I'll get one of those guys a
burner phone.
Well,
it's thousand dollars.
You wouldn't really want it as a burner
phone.
Iphone.
Yeah.
I'm leaning towards it as my main phone.
I really am.
I mean,
I'm going to say the thing about the
walled garden of iphones is you just get
used to that ecosystem.
Right now.
My,
my zone is all on my iphone.
This thing is still sweaty.
Touch it if you want to get my sweat.
Yeah,
we don't want to drink something to see
if I get that murdered sweat.
And inside me,
you just got to think like that.
Just good thing coming after someone you
love.
So wait,
let's,
let's talk about um,
so for the month and for me,
he's going to think of that in itself.
Just going to think of that.
Think of rage.
I got,
I think a killing coyotes with my bare
hands,
I think of,
I think all kinds of crazy.
She'll tell you what I'm going to.
I'm not even fucking around.
I'm going to find my inner voice that
speaks to me when I need that
exclusivity.
Find your dark place.
That's easy access for me man.
So someone said,
uh,
why is it so,
why is it so difficult to tom for Tom
Sober October?
Um,
he should take time off of thinking
about murdering Baristas.
Have you guys don't know him and his
wife had been doing this thing where you
guys had like,
if you murdered somebody,
which turned me into the cops.
She was like 100 percent and I was like,
are you out of your fucking mind?
She goes,
well,
was it an accident?
I'm like,
no,
I just told you that I killed somebody
and I got the body in the trunk and no
one knows.
She's like,
you're a psycho.
I don't know what you're going to do.
You're going to kill me next.
I'm like,
why would it kill you next?
She's like,
why'd you kill this guy?
I'm like,
because he pissed me off.
It's like,
it's like killed somebody today.
I get,
yeah,
that lady of content,
right?
So like got out of hand,
shouldn't have to go to jail forever.
You're my fucking ace,
right?
You're not going to turn me in.
She's like,
oh no,
you're unpredictable.
You can just ride or die.
That's what I thought.
Don't worry my ride or die.
You call me if you kill someone and got
the shovel ready to take it to the next
level.
If you come over with a body in the
trunk and you go,
I got a body in the trunk,
I get the shovel and you come out and
the body starts to get up out of the
trunk.
I'll hit him with a shovel,
make sure he's dead.
WHATSAPP did.
Yeah,
that was a close call.
Where are we going?
We're going to go do lot,
much fun.
We'd have figuring out a place to go
bury a body.
Yeah,
that'd be hard,
right?
Yeah.
I can tell you guys,
this is a conversation I wanted with her
and why wouldn't she do this with him?
And she's like,
I got babies now.
I fucking like,
all right.
Whatever.
Anyways,
I was just telling her,
she's like,
why did you kill the guy?
I was like,
alright,
let's just hypothetically say that on
the ride of the desert called you a cunt
so I to kill him.
I killed.
The guy called me.
I told her that he fucked up my coffee
cup.
That's definitely excusable.
She said,
she said if it's somebody like hurt the
family or something,
she was like,
then it's 100 percent.
She goes,
but if you're like laying in,
wait,
just like premeditated hanging out like
stalking people.
She goes,
Dad,
I got to turn you in.
And I'm like,
I still think that's bullshit.
Like you're my wife.
Why the fuck are you reading on me?
My wife would do the killing for me.
Someone broke into our house,
no questions asked.
I already know your wife had gun.
Somebody didn't give her the gun and
your wife,
you think you tell her she,
she,
she'd be like,
alright,
you gotta go handle this.
I knew it was coming.
All guys prepping for this,
as long as you're nice to the kids,
they go,
oh yeah man.
It's what's crazy is that used to be
super normal to kill people.
Like you mean like in the human history?
Oh yeah.
Two hundred years ago.
Yeah,
super normal people.
We have a president that killed somebody
or.
Yeah,
yeah,
it would be.
Imagine like,
um,
how normal though,
where it would be like,
it wouldn't even be worth bringing up
that you killed somebody that day.
Right?
I mean,
if you go back far enough,
it's like,
yeah,
people are just stabbed and wait,
wait,
there's there's battles on.
Do you think they had their me too
movement of,
of going like
killing people.
When did people just like totally
stopped killing people?
I don't know how to be a movement where
pure like,
guys,
my dad was murdered and no one cares and
your dad was murdered,
so can I kind of hurt me to hear this
fucking sucks man.
To like the dark ages like coming out of
that.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Dark Ages where you had no free will.
When I watch when that game of thrones,
when they cut his dick off and game of
thrones,
it kicked,
clicked with a part of me where I went,
I helplessness.
The idea that you can't go,
this isn't fair.
You're not allowed to do that.
That helplessness.
It gave me a panic attack.
Think about that.
When you're on the treadmill,
son them cut my dick off.
Or You go cutting anybody's Dick.
Oh,
let's think of that feeling.
Just think of those kinds of people out
there like helplessness.
You're tired.
You can't get away.
They,
when they bound,
I watched,
uh,
I watched the Marco Polo and thing and
when they bound that little girl's feet.
Is that,
uh,
the Netflix?
Yeah,
it was great.
I didn't watch that.
I watched like one or two episodes.
It seemed okay.
It was great and good.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
I like history.
I like anything history.
That's why I like,
like I used to have on Dan Dan Carlin
history and so Marco Polo really new
Kangaskhan apparently.
Yeah.
And so I think he knew gangas con son.
I think it's cooler.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I like history.
I'm not a stickler for details.
So.
Well,
the cons,
you know,
the rain was a long time.
I mean they,
they,
during [inaudible] lifetime,
they estimated that he killed in his
people killed 10 percent of the world's
population.
God,
they killed so many people that change
the carbon footprint of the world.
They literally change how many people
were burning things.
They literally changed it in core
samples.
Like when you do a core sample on the
earth,
the carbon footprint of human beings is
less while he was alive because he
killed one out of 10 human beings that
lived.
So he was eco.
It was eco friendly for what he did.
Yes.
It's very greasy shit.
That's a weird thing that Dan Carlin
goes over and his wrath of the con
series,
which is like one of the greatest hits
history series of all time.
Oh,
I can't recommend it enough.
I wish I could go back to the day I
found it and I was like seven part
series or whatever and I'd play it
laying in bed,
fall asleep,
wake up and have to go find out where I
left off.
So good and I'd have dreams of being a
con.
I remember having a dream of learning
how to shoot a of a page and in there we
had to wait for all four hooves off the
ground.
I had a dream because I was listening to
it sleeping.
Dude.
I had the most fun.
I'm sorry.
Keep going.
No,
go ahead.
I had the most active.
What was it?
When you dream in your wake,
lucid I the most lucid fucking dream.
Last Night Vale most lucid dream.
I walked into this closet and I was.
I was on all fours and I go,
I'm not awake.
I think I'm dreaming.
And I went,
I am dreaming.
I said,
interesting.
And I sat criss cross applesauce.
I said,
I want a beautiful woman to walk in the
closet and a beautiful woman walked into
the closet and I'm like,
I think I'm gonna.
Go down on her.
And I was like,
yeah,
this is a dream.
There's no cheating.
My wife's in Vietnam,
let's go down on her.
I started going down on her and I was
like,
where's this leading?
I think I'm going to fuck her.
Fuck her.
And then I was like,
oh yeah,
we're fucking her.
And then I woke up.
I'm like,
God damn it.
I,
I wanted to stay back in it.
She didn't want to read the fucking
biggest glitch.
Like a big black Dick.
He gets stuck in your throat.
I almost drowned.
What were you saying about the Dan
Carlin saying?
I don't remember.
Sorry.
It's okay.
Now you're going to access your rage
from,
uh,
you know,
from one of those moments.
Yeah.
Access.
You're raised thinking about how you
couldn't fuck her and you sucked her.
Dick does a lot of rage.
Super upsetting.
Yeah.
I mean,
I used to do little tricks like that to
get myself to work out harder.
That's why,
uh,
that's why I have those in my head.
That was like when I,
you know,
I just used to always feel like if,
if,
if the worst case scenario happened and
you needed energy,
like how tired are you really?
Are you really tired?
Are you tired?
Like,
oh,
I'm tired.
I just need to stop.
Or are you tired?
Like,
I can't survive right now?
Or are you tired?
Like,
someone I loved dearly is in trouble and
I can't help them.
Like,
how tired are you?
Hmm.
Yeah.
That's.
Think of that different levels of tired
for sure.
Yeah.
I'm going to put those things up
everyday.
Motherfucker.
You're going to see those images of
these workouts every day and I'm doing
two a day.
You're going to work.
Do a day like that.
Yeah.
Me Too,
I already did mine today.
I walked three miles.
I'm going to do on that bullshit fucking
treadmill that we were talking about.
These stumps treadmill.
You don't like that dude.
It just is not enjoyable because it's
hard.
It's hard as weight.
So that's the whole idea behind.
It's difficult to keep going for point
total,
right?
Is that,
that's the move,
right?
Well,
I mean there was,
there was two,
like what are the other things?
The initial thought I had was like last
year we had a,
it was 15 slash 20 minute hot yoga
classes,
so the idea was I'm going to do those
too.
Okay.
Well the idea for that was that it was
difficult but attainable.
Right.
And you had to be disciplined to do it.
So now you're going to do two workouts a
day.
Yup.
And 15 minutes.
15 million account.
The Yoga is one.
That's the one.
Okay.
I'll work out today.
But.
And then another hardcore.
I'm doing the 15 hot yoga classes on top
of all the other shit.
What is this number?
The one that's your calories burned.
Oh really?
That's what I said.
When you walked in,
I've never once been burned a thousand
calories to workout,
so I take that bunch.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
What's a normal workout burn?
I mean,
if you're doing an intense one.
Oh,
here.
I'll show you.
I got a bunch of them locked in here.
It says 98 percent of my secondary job.
It's going to adjust.
Yeah,
because it's one 75.
it's going to drink is because I'm an
old fuck.
It just thinks my heart rate doesn't go
that high anymore.
Here I'm on.
The juice numbers starts to says like
it's 2:20
minus your age is your Max heart rate
zone or something like that.
Well that's not real.
So yeah,
the older you are,
the lower your Max's.
Well that's broken.
The Shit don't work,
right?
I should be dead.
This is where it should be.
I don't think that's like the year or.
I did a workout a couple of days ago.
Sixty three minutes.
Seventy two percent effort throughout.
Eight hundred 64 calories burned.
That's a lot.
Eight hundred says yeah,
that's a good workout.
Yeah.
And then this one,
that was 62 minute workouts.
I would you said?
Yeah,
this was a 93 minute workout.
I burned 1300 calories.
And a real.
Yeah,
you could do that.
You can do that,
but you'd have to go hog hole hall.
This was kickboxing.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
You did a 90 minute kickbox we did
kickboxing for part of it.
And then you've got a trainer now?
Yeah.
Oh,
could you let Mr Tommy money bags a
couple of netflix specials.
Sell out a few theaters.
He's not saying he's doing more than the
no theaters.
Presold sale.
Sold out everything out.
Everything.
When you move into arenas.
Hey,
speaking of arenas,
how was Toronto fucking insane?
What is it like in the.
When you're doing 10,000
people,
10,000,
600 people at the Scotia Bank or he was
the Air Canada Center at the UFC is back
there in December.
I'm back.
They're easy to be like,
oh,
one time I was here alone talking.
And then you see it like filled for
events like that.
And that's where the fucking raptors
play it.
It's,
it's so ridiculous.
It doesn't seem real,
but I got to say the show felt like as
intimate as a set at the store,
I'm not bullshitting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was,
it was fucking nuts.
So yeah.
Yeah,
it was fucking easy peasy.
It was fun.
I mean it was literally like any other
set I was.
I was nervous that I wasn't nervous.
I was nervous that I was calm and I did
a lot of sets leading up to it.
Like when I did a,
you know,
I constantly do sets,
but I did like,
I did four sets Thursday night.
Ideally.
Yeah,
I did the ice house Wednesday,
so I did an hour plus the ice house.
I did three sets on,
on Tuesday night.
Yeah,
I mean that's.
I think that's the key is you just gotta
do gotta be.
Yeah.
You have to just do so many that you're,
you're just just like working out.
You can't have any doubt.
You gotta be in shape.
I just sent you a video.
This is,
this shows you how ridiculous the crowd
booked,
but when you're a,
but you're also getting used to arenas
because you did a few now just weird
boozer fourth,
Rena,
fourth,
maybe fifth.
But did,
did.
Um,
Columbus Vancouver.
Did Columbus.
Did Kansas City.
Kansas City was weird because outside.
That was weird.
It was like an amphitheater,
right?
Yeah.
Crazy.
This was the biggest one.
This one was bananas.
Wild Man.
I'm stressing top of are doing tours at
the exact same time next year and I'm
stressing doing theaters 12.
So $1,200
in the theater going like,
fuck it.
How do you like it gets normal man after
awhile.
But scooter scooter had dessert a couple
of seconds and you can see it when I get
onstage,
like,
like watch when they turn the lights on,
this is what's really strange
when you get to look out over the entire
audience.
Fucking ridiculous.
That's madness.
That is that wild man do that.
Then there's the upper deck that doesn't
seem real and it just happened.
And you,
you did this and the same night a
bird did the forum burdens.
Not 20,000,
9,000,
the Western Forum,
the Great Western Forum.
I don't know that it is the thing online
that it was 20,000
people.
They're wrong because Dean del Ray said
it was 9,000.
I think they just made a mistake but
huge.
Either way.
It's huge.
So I was thinking last night,
I know you,
I know that you're not like this,
I know you're a little bit like this,
but to compare different times of
comedy,
right?
Um,
and compare people.
I know you don't like comparing people,
but has there ever been a time in comedy
where this many acts were selling
arenas?
This many acts were selling theaters and
this maniacs we're selling out clubs.
I don't think so.
He will.
Well,
burrs sold out Madison Square Garden,
which is way bigger than that.
Madison Square Garden I think is
$18,000.
How about this?
Sebastian is ready to sell for car.
He's already sold out three.
He's opened up a fourth show at Madison
Square Garden.
Just stop and think about that.
That's almost 80,000
people.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's like a fucking nfl game stadium
at this time.
Like just look at theater comics.
Just legit selling like multiple theater
shows.
Eliza Dalea.
You can name any of you myself,
like,
Oh,
you go down the list.
There's so many comics selling theaters,
theaters that I don't think there's ever
been,
you know,
there's never been a time like this.
Never.
There's never been this many comics are
settling out multiple thousand seat
places.
And then there's the big first of all
this Kevin Hart,
who's the biggest of the big.
He sells out 50,000.
Carol Williams is actually a lot bigger
than he is.
Kat Williams.
Oh yeah.
I watched it on the breakfast club.
I'm joking.
Didn't he got Williams?
Just slamming potential.
Pretty Fun.
I liked that.
I liked,
I liked tattoos,
but he's,
he's eccentric at best.
Kevin is the biggest,
the biggest.
It's the biggest monster.
So he's fit.
He can sell 50,000.
He sold $50,000.
Philadelphia when he did a special.
Yeah,
there's only one of him,
but you know,
it was real close to him that people
forget about is Larry the cable guy?
Because Larry,
the cable guy was selling out football
stadiums because Josh Wolfe was opening
for him and Josh Wolfe took a picture
and showed it to me and he goes,
dude,
this was me onstage opening up for Larry
the cable guy.
And you're like,
yeah,
but people don't think about.
First of all,
Larry,
the cable guy is the most humble.
Like plus he's doing that in like the
heartland.
So people will just dismiss it because
it's not like an la show or so.
Those two guys,
I think.
I think Kevin Hart is Numero Uno.
He's number one.
Yeah.
And then there's Chappelle could
basically do anything.
He sells out mass the forum,
not the form of the Hollywood bowl.
A bowl.
Yeah.
That's huge.
What does that $20,000,
$20,000
is amphitheatre offers like left and
right.
And then they'll,
you know,
they'll probably be like,
Eh,
you do a show.
It's like you'll get like $700,000,
be like,
I'm going to do the belly room.
And then he just goes and does that
because he likes it.
He likes the intimate shows.
Well,
he's also,
I hate to use a term like this,
but he's a legitimate artist.
He's just trying to do better work to
better comedy and always evolve it.
He's one of the rare guys that could do
a special and then the next week 11 new
our.
Yeah,
and somehow it comes out works.
I know.
I mean he's just supremely dedicated,
you know?
Yeah.
So there's him,
there's Chris Rock can still sell out
pretty big places.
If Louis came back,
I think he could sell out giant places.
Giant burst sells out everywhere he
wants to burke and sell out.
He sold out Boston Garden,
which is 18,000
wells fargo center in Philly.
How big is that?
15,000.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
He could sell out all those places.
It's really hard to put in perspective,
and I think you guys can understand
this,
but I mean you were selling out clubs
what,
like six,
17 years ago.
Were you just doing clubs?
Yeah,
for sure,
but when you were,
when you were selling them,
when you were selling out just clubs,
that's an achievement in this business
to sell out weekends and ad shows is a
login achievement that so undermined
when you go in and use San Jose or you
do whatever.
You sell out everything and then go,
oh my God,
like Holy Shit.
Like there's,
there's.
So the possibilities are endless.
Well,
it's the Internet.
It's,
that's what it is.
It's people.
And then there's like this network of
comics now that everybody knows about,
you know,
if you know about bill,
you know about Joey Diaz,
you know about you,
you know,
but there's this thing going on now
where everyone's sort of connected
that's never existed before.
And then a lot of these people,
not Sebastian,
he's one of the rare ones that doesn't.
But most of these people have podcasts.
Kevin Hart doesn't obviously,
but Kevin Hart has major movies.
Sebastian actually does one.
He does a podcast.
I didn't even know,
but I don't think they,
I don't think he can get to it like
weekly,
but they definitely considered serious
thinking to do it specifically for
serious.
Does it?
Whenever you can get to it.
Think so.
I think you've probably been,
you've been in this longest of the three
of us,
but have you ever known a time in comedy
when comics were more friendly?
Like it seems like everyone's on the
same team.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
This is a completely different thing.
I've talked about this before.
It's because I really believe it's
because the internet and also because
there's
no,
um,
things were fighting for anymore.
Like tonight show spots are stupid shit
like that or Sitcom auditions.
But in the past it was like there was
three channels and there was the tonight
show and the letterman show and
everybody wanted to host the tonight
show,
but Jay Leno was hosting it forever or
Johnny Carson before him and there was
this competition between comics when
they were just cut throat and there's
not that anymore now instead,
like radio shows,
right?
Radio shows always shit on the other
radio shows always.
They always saw other morning shows in
town.
They shit on him.
It was all shitting on.
Everybody fucked them.
Like Howard stern was notorious for it.
Yeah.
We do the opposite.
Start wars for ratings.
Yeah,
but we do the opposite.
We all have successful podcast,
but we all have each other on our
podcasts.
We're all super friendly about it.
We all promote each other's specials.
We all,
we all hang out together.
Like there's a camaraderie amongst
comedians now.
It used to be like there might be some
comradery amongst a couple,
but it would always go bad.
You know,
that there was never like bunch of real
headliners hanging out together like
they are now.
Yeah.
I mean even the simplest things like
Dalea does something funny and I'll just
put it,
I'll talk about it all my open tabs and
get like half a million views and then
you just go like I deleted.
It might be one of my favorite people to
watch these days because I just watched
his instagram will go,
what's he doing today?
He's ridiculous.
I can totally talk about it all my open
tabs and just share it with everyone.
I just go,
oh,
great.
Bernie shop.
But like,
dude,
it's been funny shit.
Dean del Ray Singh.
Yeah,
I saw you posted that up.
It's got.
Okay.
So I put that on my instagram is another
good example.
I put that on my instagram and it's got
like 700,000
unique.
It really saying fuck him.
Like he can really sing like what?
Like wait a minute,
I didn't know you could do that.
Yeah,
it's got 670,000
days living his best life man.
I told
them,
I go send me the whole fucking video,
man,
you,
you.
I go,
you're a fucking murder a man.
He's an inspiration man.
He didn't,
he did Conan tonight.
I did Conan and he was so excited and it
was so amazing to like burst showed
up.
Everyone was in the back of the room and
he came off.
He was like,
that's my first late night as well and I
think Dean's 50.
You got to respect it though.
He just started stand up like 46 or
something.
Something like that.
Yeah.
It's very.
It's not.
It's not common.
It's not common to stick with it and
keep getting better at it.
It was so cool to be on the end of Kona
with him.
Marin,
Marin and dean.
Just three comics and that's booking,
but there's no celebrity.
It's just three comics and deans.
The only one that did stand up and just
like,
oh fuck.
Yeah.
That's what I saw someone said it was.
It felt like the green room at the main
room and the comedy store.
Burrs limit.
Let me tell you something.
I.
Burr Bill Burr is living as best fucking
life right now.
He does these when he does the garden or
when he does the forum,
they come in with the goddamn comedy jam
and set up a thing and they do a full
concert to an empty venue before the
show.
They just do it for themselves.
They just want to play the forum.
He'll tell me he played from two to
6:30.
Really?
Yeah,
just played all day,
so I was exhausted.
He was.
I was worried.
I was too tired to do the show.
Hilarious.
But that's how much fun he is having
done.
Do.
What would you do if you did like would
you set up a football game and football?
Yeah.
What would you do,
man?
I mean,
I would watch one.
I would just invite people to come watch
a game.
That means fucking flying helicopters.
Playing drums.
I mean,
yeah.
Yeah.
No,
he's not.
This is an interesting time,
but this is also.
It shows you that because of all this
camaraderie and that everybody's doing
really well,
it shows you that that's possible,
that these,
the old way of looking at things as the
wrong way.
Yeah,
that's a selfish famine thinking way
wrong.
Well,
hire a Dj to bring me out to an event
like that though.
If I was doing an arena.
Really does that.
I think Chappelle does that.
Russell brought out a MC Shan out on,
always brings on stage to all his white
audience and he freestyled the use all
the breaks and all the white people just
sat there staring at Russell and Russell
was like,
are you fucking kidding me?
He's.
He brings like old school legends
everywhere.
Well,
he,
he'll do a gig and then after a gig
he'll go to a club and DJ.
Yeah,
he will.
He can actually Dj to real dj DJ records
and scratching and all that stuff.
He knows his shit.
He gets mad at those electronic music
guys would call themselves Djs,
DJ,
Dj.
He's goes back like,
you got to be able to get vinyl.
Dig through the crates.
Yeah.
Flip it around.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
he knows his stuff,
man.
He really does.
Well,
he's another one that sells out.
He's at that other place.
A place that I was at in November.
Really?
Yeah.
He's at the Scotia Bank.
He's done that.
A bunch.
Hometown selling out giant places.
There's so much of that going on with
his seven time doing that too.
Oh yeah.
At least it's overwhelming,
man.
It really is,
and I,
I,
you know what it is.
I had a guy say to me one time,
and I think this is what it is.
I had a guy come up to me at West Palm,
was doing a New Year's eve
drunk as fuck.
Both of us probably were both shirtless.
I'm doing the meet and greet and he
goes,
ah.
He goes,
I need to talk to you for like two
minutes and the artist is that you
wanted to fuck,
you know,
I get this a lot.
I get,
I'm good.
Thanks.
I'm done.
He agreed,
and so I go there like,
sir,
you got to move along and give them two
minutes.
And he's like,
he's like,
dude,
I'm a fan.
Do you know what that means?
I was like,
hey.
And he goes,
no,
you're not listening to me when you do.
Well,
I get happy.
He's like,
it makes me happy to see good things
happen to you.
I will always be a fan,
will always support you.
And I,
as soon as he said that,
I thought it sounds super silly,
but I'm.
Before I met you,
I was a fan like when you,
when that,
when the Carlos stuff went down,
I got,
I've got behind your back and I was
like,
I'm a fan of Joe's.
I like what he's doing that he's
standing up for me.
And in a weird way,
being a fan of something so fucking fun
when you become a fan and I think what
podcasts have done is allowed you to
enter by become intimate with your fans
and they support you in a way.
Like people go out and they see a video
of dns singing and they go,
oh yeah,
I'm happy.
We're all happy for him when you do
10,000
seats,
I think there are people going,
fuck yeah man,
my guys winning.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
no,
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
I think we're fans of each other too.
That's big too.
They also,
people realize like,
hey,
like you can be a fan of someone.
It doesn't mean that somehow or another
you're a lesser person.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm sure bill burr is a fan of
Chappelle.
I'm sure Chappelle's a fan of Chris
Rock,
like people are fans of other people's
art.
Whereas I think in the past that wasn't
the case.
It was not.
It was about separate camps.
Yeah.
I was like,
I'm in this year on that side,
which is so dumb,
so dumb.
Because you can also,
it's like,
you know,
you can like,
you can like one type of music the most,
but still enjoy other music that when
the Internet opened up all these
possibilities,
that's when it happened.
Probably seems like it to me.
I think it was podcasting.
Yes.
Like pea pod casting,
I guess.
Yeah.
That is the Internet.
I'm sorry,
I was thinking of Youtube for some
reason,
but like can you imagine dice and
kinison they hated each other.
Hated each other.
That was the way it works.
That was the bullet hole at the store.
Oh,
the belly room store.
Sam kinison brought a gun and shot the
fucking sign to let dice.
Now that he was going to fucking shoot
him.
He didn't just pull out a gun.
He pulled out a gun and shot a fucking
sign.
It's really crazy.
Yeah.
They just fixed it a few years ago.
I was mad when they fix it.
I'll fix that.
Yeah.
It's really crazy though.
Yeah,
got it.
I got to start doing that to you,
burt.
Just shooting guns and guns and guns on
name.
Shoot it and shoot designed.
Yeah,
but I think those guys were doing co two
and we smoked pot.
That's way different ingredients to this
whole thing.
He smoked pot.
You want to hug people,
you do coke.
You like,
you want to fight,
bro?
Fuck you up.
I'll hold you down.
I'll fuck your mouth.
Fuck your mother.
Fuck your mothers.
Mother fucker.
Bones.
That'll start a business.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's also,
there was everyone's scratching and
clawing.
There wasn't a lot of opportunities.
I think it's the pot tooth though.
I think it's like guys like Diaz as an
Ren,
you and me,
like there's a different sensibility.
There's like a,
a more generous sensibility.
I think.
So give me an.
I think it's everything for me.
I'm,
I'm big.
I'm big on generosity and I'm big on
support.
I think you have to do that with people
around you.
You become contagious too.
Yeah.
You know,
when you have it done to you,
you want to do it for others for sure.
Yeah.
It's giant.
Help out opening acts.
Help out other comments.
And as you rise up,
they'll do the same.
They'll do the same for the other guys
and you see them doing that for a little
start taking guys with them on the road
and around.
Look,
Ben,
who do we like more than comics and
where?
What do you,
who do you want to hang out with more
than comedians?
You know,
there were the most fun for us to hang
out with what we could say ridiculous
shit and then we'll laugh at it.
We won't like.
Well,
I don't know why it said that.
Tommy,
you shouldn't have called that lady at
con.
Especially not at friend.
And then,
you know,
I think you owe or a sauna and apology.
I mean if I was on I would've clocked
you.
Yeah.
It's like the people wouldn't think it's
funny.
Of course,
if you were working at Xerox and he said
all that people would,
you know,
they'd bring you into your liability.
We've got to let you go.
Got to go.
It's true.
I know when those are the worst people
that get stuck at a dinner with or
something,
you know,
you're like,
oh shit.
You just torture him.
Yeah.
It's the worst.
Yeah,
I used to feel terrible when I was
around those people.
I used to feel like there's something
wrong with me.
Yeah,
because yeah,
of course.
Real stuck up super conservative people.
I would just think there's something
wrong with me.
Why do I think this way?
Why do I always want to say the
inappropriate thing?
It's like a muscle twitch.
Go.
Just see how far you can make it a
course.
You start talking,
be in a foot race.
Oh my God.
You just see eyes widen and they're
like,
yeah,
you're like,
dude,
we're not at a seminar right now,
and that's what's bullshit about
seminars.
Yeah,
I mean,
imagine if you were in the world of
business.
See,
I really think this is one of the
reasons why so many people are so fucked
up.
It's so depressed.
I think the world of showing to,
showing up to a place and then having
your behavior limited into this very
narrow and rigid parameters all day long
and your livelihood and your success of
your,
your family and whether or not you can
send your kids to a good school.
All that dependent upon whether or not
you're willing to play the rules,
you have to wear an outfit with a suit
and tie because if you don't,
you might be unpredictable and you show
up with that t shirt on.
He's got a football shirt on at work.
What the fuck is he drunk?
What is crazy?
He's doing drugs.
You can't
little join around people that don't
just like joints around people crashed.
Tesla's stock
by $9,000,000,000
or some stupid shit.
So crazy.
Yeah,
but not really.
It bounced right back into that world.
Like the guy can't.
First of all,
we were drinking whisky.
Okay.
No one has a problem with that,
which is way more of a hard drug.
Way more of a crazy drug than a little
puff of a joint.
We were drinking whiskey.
No one cared.
We drank whiskey for three hours.
Smoked a little joint.
Oh,
let you think.
He inhaled it.
Didn't look like it didn't look like it
just took a ninth grader.
He didn't know what to do.
It took a little puff.
You know,
new kid at school just gets.
Everyone just wants to do it too.
No bad.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
He didn't.
I mean another layer of it.
He did it in California.
Exactly.
Totally.
Totally legal.
Yeah.
It's no different than having that class
of whiskey.
You know,
California said you could fly with it.
Now what?
Lex said,
you could have an ounce of weed with you
on the airplane.
They said,
we don't know what the fuck's going to
happen when you land somewhere where you
can go through lax with an ounce of
weed.
I'm sorry.
By the way,
I looked up private suite after I talked
to you.
Super expensive.
So expensive,
stupid,
expensive.
How did you know about it?
Sam Harris?
He told me about it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
Mike.
I like people.
I don't mind going to the airport and
saying hi to people that that thing is
like $7,000
a flight.
It's pretty.
It was wild trivia.
No,
no,
I think it was $3,000.
It's a membership.
I thought the membership was it and
they're like,
membership gets you,
so you pay 4,500
to be a member and then $2,700
for a domestic flight per flight for
like your own entrance.
Uh,
you know,
whatever your own meals you're on,
check in your own a Tsa Room.
You hang out and make it sounded cool
for like,
like a family vacation or something.
You know,
if you're Chris Pratt,
it's definitely makes sense.
Yeah.
Summer,
a list,
actor type person who shouldn't go
anywhere.
Yeah,
if you're Tom Cruise.
But he said,
but those guys,
they have to fly private.
They do.
They own their own planes.
Most of them,
you know,
they get.
There's some article online about John
Travolta's yacht pull up John Travolta's
yacht.
It's probably got a bet if you went over
that fucking thing with a black light.
It was level like a Jackson pollock
painting.
Just pretty fucking splatters Jesus just
got a new yet everywhere.
Apparently by the cabin boy.
This place really is lightened up.
Boy Place.
Got Five locks on the door,
lock bolts on the inside.
I'm outside.
All the deckhands are really worn out
here.
Yes.
You have very weird latex outfits for
them to where?
Oh yeah.
It's the money that that fucking guy
must have.
God,
he's got his own jet and he has his own
jet jet.
He has a seven.
40 seven?
Yeah.
Seven 47.
Yes.
And he has a runway and his for.
He
has like multiple planes,
like look at that full story behind
Toronto's private jet fleet.
Like he's got his arm out the window.
It flies to the window.
Fucking commercial plane.
Yeah.
In the back room is just.
It's all like a slip and slide with baby
oil.
I look at that.
Look how many you have got multiple
gulfstreams.
If he flew for Quantus as a commercial
pilot.
He did.
Yes.
He.
They actually let him flop.
He's that good of a pilot.
Wow.
That I think he has some sort of
commercial standing with Quantas.
He has a military jet just in case
someone calls Homo flies over and flux.
That's really crazy.
Mad at him asking to get a hand job at a
massage.
See?
Yeah.
That's.
It's funny stories about it,
but this hash tag baller.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
That is bawling.
That's a crazy man.
I mean that's like $100,000,000
yacht right there.
Where,
where did he make all his money?
I mean,
how much money do you make from like
pulp fiction hit that one.
That would be about being a Russian spy
or teaching or his forte,
you know,
like his,
like his wealth,
wealth,
wasn't he?
He'd kind of depleted when pulp fiction
was like around [inaudible] 93.
Yeah.
And then that made him so famous and hot
again that he was just,
he was a $20,000,000
movie guy for for a while.
That was lasting face off.
Yeah.
All those days off.
So he's.
But he's doing terrible movies now.
Yeah.
Izzy?
You did that movie.
It's supposed to be.
We should probably have a fight
companion for God.
I heard it was really bad.
I've heard it's so bad.
You wish.
Do you wish to do November rolls around?
We can get drunk again.
Yeah.
That's good.
That hammered and watch this God movie.
It's supposed to be a wretched sack of
shit.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
We'll do that because we've been being
to do that.
What was the other terrible movie we're
meaning to do that with?
I have it on his head.
Auror that movie about.
Well,
that's right.
That's right.
There was a movie where a guy who was a
lion trainer actually made a movie with
lions and a bunch of people that were
making the thing.
Oh,
play the play the clip.
Let's hear the clip.
Hmm?
Nah,
hold on.
Do you have the wrong music plan that
this is.
This is a scene slash trailer from
Godaddy.
Say That on the cover of the paper.
Wait a minute.
Music.
The music is really the sting song.
That's how it was.
Pizza Shit movie.
This is the trailer sucks.
Look at this as like an acting class.
Good.
Let it play out.
Oh,
hold on a second.
I'm sure to pull the audio off.
Oh,
well we'll do Youtube Yankees for the
audio.
You look at them.
There's a look.
So fake.
No.
Okay.
Kill it.
We can't do this.
This is so bad,
I can't even do a mobster anymore.
It's like it feels like a joke to play.
You could do it,
but it would have to be like,
do you have to be authentic James
Gandolfini back to life.
Like if James Gandolfini was alive
today,
he could be a movie.
Yeah,
sure.
Because you believed it,
right?
It's got to be authentic.
Yeah.
You'd believe it,
but he gotta be.
It's gotta be done.
I mean,
Scorsese,
you could probably do it again,
like it's just.
There's just a bunch of people.
He's got a new one coming when he's
playing young.
God,
he just looks like a grown up.
Danny Zuko.
Hey.
Apparently Danny,
Danny in the greasers tell you what,
man.
After the sopranos came on the air,
everybody wanted to be Italian.
It was one of those gross moments in
time where all these Italians were like
empowered and they were all talking like
goon Baas and they,
they,
they all wanted to fucking get together
and have pasta on old pecan pies.
Like ramped it up,
say Matsuura.
Most of them started doing the hand
gestures,
like the guys come out of that going on
and you know,
as a person who's legitimately Italian,
it was disgusting.
You fucking apes.
Are you doing?
Yeah,
you,
he's,
yeah.
They ramped it up,
you know,
and then like Greek people are like,
I'm a Italian.
Start pretending that they're designed
for sure.
It was,
you know,
there was a time where there was so many
auditions for so many fucking movies
that we're talking about a town all
Italians.
What is this life on the line?
It's another,
a power line guy.
By the way.
We should this.
This is probably worse for sure.
Fuck.
How about urban cowboy?
That's the premise of urban cowboy.
Urban Cowboy.
He worked on the line,
will have a double feature.
I thought our night.
Well we'll play God and we'll play life
on the line and we'll sync.
We'll have people sync it up.
This is what.
We'll do this,
mark those to mark those two movies and
so we'll get those on the Netflix and
we'll,
after sober October is over,
we'll get fucking hammered.
Will bring a five gallon jug,
a Tito's in here to movies and I love
it.
I love it.
I rented a Bruce Willis one to laugh at
like I was like,
this is going to be a piece of shit.
And it didn't get,
it didn't get bad until like 25 minutes
were left.
I was actually,
this is pretty good.
It was this,
uh,
I think it's called deathwish,
which is a death wish.
Bruce Willis?
Yeah.
And it was actually really well done
until like third act really.
Then it fell apart,
but I'm watching it like this is going
to be a piece of shit and 30 minutes.
Am I sick?
Good fucking movie.
It was like with the snowman.
Did you
see the snowman?
Mm.
Yeah.
That was a snowman.
Death wish.
Bruce Willis is better than I thought.
Yeah,
I thought it was going to.
He got delayed for some reason why they
get delayed because of mass shootings or
something.
Oh boy.
I think so,
yeah.
Something along those lines.
Six point four.
And I am deb.
I mean the trailer got real dog shit.
Yeah.
You talking to me,
a guy I enjoyed Hudson Hawke.
I was a big part was man,
eight percent rotten tomatoes.
The snowman is.
Spoiler alert.
The snowman ends.
It's this guy.
Don't spoil it.
It's.
It's so ridiculous.
It's so fucking ridiculous.
What's it about?
It's about a serial killer who a snowman
is leaving.
Snowman says hints and he's cutting off
body parts and then arranging them in
the snow.
So fast vendor is a alcoholic cop who is
trying to solve it.
Who's Michael fassbender music from
promethium it.
See the robot from takes place abroad,
right?
Isn't it takes place,
but may have.
I don't want to talk negatively,
but val kilmer,
his performance is so disturbing that
you.
It pulls you out.
The movie immediately is terrible on it.
Knows when he's going through the throat
stuff and they dubbed his voice in this.
They had him dub his voice so they took
out his voice because he couldn't
understand them I guess.
And then they had.
They dumped his voice move.
I mean,
it's like,
it's so bad that it throwed pills you
out and you're like,
you definitely should have just not had
him in the movie and let him get
healthy.
I think he's doing better now.
Hopefully.
No,
I think he is.
I think he's gone into remission,
you know.
I'll tell you what,
man,
he fucking stole the show.
And Wyatt earp.
Remember that kilmer?
Amiya huckleberry.
Remember that Shit.
You name all the moon.
He,
uh,
the doors he was murdered.
He was a monster.
Marus val kilmer is a motherfucker
genius.
CV can get that scene from hint with val
kilmer as a white,
a dark holiday.
Dark holiday in wider.
The funniest piece of shit he made.
Did you see the.
I like the saint and I like the
superhero movie right now.
That was like a spy.
Like I play again.
I get in disguise.
Cranked.
This is the very end.
Hold on.
Okay.
The audio we pull up.
This is a great fucking scene and this
is a great scene.
Just the thing about the scene as you
believe it,
you just believe him.
Well,
not dude,
realize it's the wrong guy.
I didn't understand the scene until
recently.
People can't hear this on youtube.
No.
Okay,
so can talk.
Yeah.
I didn't understand that.
He's.
This is him.
The reason that I didn't understand why
the guy was scared.
It's because doc holiday wants to die in
a gunfight.
Yeah,
because he's dying.
Yeah.
He wants to be shot.
But also he was killing everybody.
Doc Holliday was a fucking monster and
this guy was a want to be bad ass and he
realized that Doc Holliday was going to
fuck them up.
I've never seen this.
You never saw this serious.
I don't like Westerns.
I hate horses.
You hate horses?
I do hate horses.
I.
I've just never liked.
This is about fucking horses.
Tom.
I don't like this time.
I don't like this.
I don't like the aesthetic.
I don't like their hats.
I've seriously.
I really.
I'm serious.
I don't like any of it.
Are you shitting me?
One of the best movies ever.
Not Interested because occasionally they
get on a horse and I don't like their
hats.
Yeah.
Can you look lower?
Yeah,
still bothers me.
I like the mustaches.
Okay.
Sweaty is.
Yeah,
we got close.
They are to each other.
Do you think people really just did that
close to each other and had gunfights oh
yeah.
Dun,
Dun.
I wouldn't mind doing a gunfight with
you Tom.
Oh Shit.
Come on.
He wants him to shoot him now.
Wow.
It doesn't seem as good.
Second time around.
Maybe in the context of the entire
movie.
I love these mustaches.
They all look like alt comics now.
Kurt Russell was weird.
I must make a batch to ice cream.
Wait a minute.
Comics are all comics really anymore.
I felt like that does evaporated as
real.
I think it's still real.
It's one of my favorite things.
Watching all comics go up in the main
room.
Yeah.
You see it,
you know the,
um,
they kind of get walk in shell shocked.
They already know that it's not that
their crowd.
You could see.
I didn't realize what that was until you
just said it.
I've seen it before and I've always been
like,
oh,
this is your first time here.
You can see in their eyes and you're
like,
oh,
you're gonna.
Love it.
This is the greatest team in the world.
Yeah,
man.
It's so funny to get more aggressive.
You can tell.
It's like a natural get aggressive about
being progressive.
Motherfuckers aggressively progressive.
Yeah.
I remember when all was like thought of
as you were.
If you were all.
You were like soft and progressive and
sensitive and kind.
Now alt is right,
like all right,
you think of,
you think of outright
like that's all you hear about now.
It's like,
all right.
Which is like assholes.
You think of racism,
xenophobia,
like the word all got sort of hijack.
That's true.
Yeah.
I didn't even think about that,
but it does.
You say,
Oh,
most people's mind will definitely go
outright over the last few years,
but like in the context in the world of
comedy,
it actually oddly usually implied
somebody who's probably far to the left.
Yeah,
but only with us.
I think only within income with
audiences.
I don't think they even know that
expression anymore.
I feel like true all universally
publicly has sort of been hijacked by.
All right,
or at least the definition of it
hijacked by outright people.
That's true.
That is true,
right?
I don't.
Yeah,
I guess so.
I,
I assume there's got to be an ot left,
right?
Well,
I think
was,
but I think the problem is once you say
all now everybody just thinks,
right.
See,
I would have automatically turned out.
Left.
Sounds made up.
Yeah.
What?
What is,
what are the alternative to the right of
the ideas?
It's young,
right?
So.
Okay.
But assholes.
So like the right.
If you think of conservative,
you would think of like Lindsey Graham,
you think of people that are probably
racist,
but they keep it up.
Slippery shoes and the Lindsey Graham
was a chick until this week.
I literally went,
that's it,
dude.
I thought it was a $6,000,000
woman.
Oh,
he's got that southern accent that you
can't tell if it's gay or not.
It's the same thing.
It's like,
oh,
well I'll do the quail.
Yeah.
There's,
this is weird watching these cavenaugh
hearings.
The whole thing is so strange.
Oh,
you gotta you gotTa.
Keep your head down if you do not agree
with the.
Like I,
I just,
I just tweeted that.
Uh,
can you imagine defending your high
school yearbook?
That's all I tweeted.
I saw that and it was a fucking shit
show.
I saw that.
Yeah.
And I was like,
I'm fucking out.
You can't.
People can't recognize that you're not
in support of this guy.
You're not in support of anything like,
but it's,
it's a real thing and virtue signal
simply show that people know,
Oh,
I'm on your team.
I'm just,
I'm just a fucking comedian.
I'm just making an observation early.
Can you imagine defending your six year
high school yearbook?
You remember Hicks is bit about Clarence
Thomas.
No,
no.
I'm sure I've heard it.
Hicks had a bit about Clarence Thomas
when they were.
They were trying to bring him into
Supreme Court.
Oh Man.
I wish I could remember exactly how the
bit went,
but it was a great bit,
but it was about his porn collection.
You know,
like Mr Hare?
Oh yes,
yes,
yes.
Familiar at all with clam lap was
volumes one through all of them.
Says all of them.
Yeah,
it was just like this funny bit like
examining.
That was funny by the way.
Lindsay Graham,
what do you see like after he left,
where they decided they voted on that
they're going to.
Well,
they voted that's going to move to the
floor,
but they decided like,
you know,
we'll try to do this extra week of,
uh,
the FBI investigation and then he goes,
somebody's going to have to explain this
to trump.
I guess that'll be me.
The press basically is a not so subtle
way of being like,
dum,
dum doesn't get it.
So I'll trump said to one of the fucking
reporters today,
now what a female reporter said.
He goes,
he pointed to a woman and he said,
go ahead.
And he goes,
she can't,
she's speechless.
She can't believe I,
I,
I called on her and she goes,
well,
I didn't think.
He goes,
yeah,
you don't think,
I get that.
I'm sorry.
And she goes,
I'm sorry sir,
like,
listen to this.
Listen to this,
You never do let's,
let's say this.
Listen this.
He can't help himself.
He's crazy.
Yeah,
she's shocked that I picked her state of
shock.
I'm not thinking that.
That's okay.
I know you're not thinking you never do.
No,
go ahead.
Why that's president.
That's such a crazy thing to say to
someone.
Yeah.
No,
I know.
You're not thinking you never do.
She must be someone that's written
really negative things about you.
He knows,
you know,
he's got that hit list and everything.
Is this a piece of shit?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Of course.
It's all things madness.
He keeps a record here.
They have records of,
you know,
anyone who's slided.
Um,
anyone who's written anything bad said
anything for sure man.
See,
I'm not,
I'm not a confrontational.
I don't like confrontation.
So part,
there's part of me that goes,
uh,
like I always thought I wish Kim Jong Un
would be a fan so I could go over and
party with him for a week.
What?
You don't think that way?
Yeah.
What luth dictators and party with him,
Bro.
You want to party with him?
I would really like free Adele Castro
would have been crazy to dense robin if
you went over there,
partied with him.
And then just like,
I don't know,
like the next morning when you're like,
I had the best time,
he was like,
send them to a labor camp.
Fuck this guy.
Fuck you want to lose some weight?
How about I give you one grain of rice a
day,
man,
that would be fun.
And you drank piss my pis.
That's it.
You want stay hydrated is a jug of pis.
I guess I'm the only one that thinks
that way.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
No one wants to go party with them.
We talked with the fucking ruthless
dictator.
You get offered a private gig.
They're like,
hey man,
it's an.
It's a,
it's in Pyongyang.
Seemed to fly you private.
Are we getting paid before?
I kind of need a little bit upfront.
I think maybe deposit,
flight,
private.
It's going to be really amazing.
[inaudible] a million dollar super
private.
You know what?
Flying privates like sitting down.
So awesome.
Just sitting down.
Why?
Why would they be amazing?
You're sitting.
Yeah.
It's nothing.
It's not like you're flying private
people rubbing your feet and sucking
your Dick.
No ice cream.
Ice Cream movies.
Playing the music is fucking full.
Three d surround sound.
You could make those things happen if
you want.
Yeah,
if you want to fly private.
Dan Bilzerian probably does that.
When he flies.
It's the draw for flying private.
I obviously I can't afford it.
Omega three or four days just wouldn't
make any money on the road.
But is that you get done and you go
home,
you get done and you go to a.
You get on a plane and you fly home or
you just wait 20 minutes and you saved
$30,000.
Not Twenty minutes.
Wouldn't be nice to get on a plane.
You fly private.
You fucking cock done it.
Are you calling that?
God has no idea.
He's just making them a cup.
You fly private though.
I don't fly private and you have flow
private for like a couple of times but
it's never like.
Because I was like,
ah,
I just got to get home.
It was.
Instead of doing crazy transpo to get to
a Gig for a short of short flight though
I don't do it like on a red,
call them out,
call them out for flying private.
I saw that because I never thought about
it in the news like when.
That'd be nice.
And I was like,
yeah,
well you know,
it's one of the grossest celebrity
things ever is the posing in front of
the private jet.
Dude doesn't know what all the Comedians
don't do that though because that's all
I guess they do.
Yeah.
I'm black ones but I'm saying this,
not our friends.
Oh,
I know.
A few that suck.
That do it.
Yeah.
I've seen.
Are you looking at me looking at you
because you know who I'm talking about.
I mean there's only.
You can do it too.
It's just a weird thing.
It's like it would definitely pose in
front of it shirtless.
You know?
He would.
What?
Would it be weird if we were all on a
private jet flying somewhere and we post
this stuff.
Would that be okay?
Yeah,
because that's like dig in Aspen to
celebrate.
After sober October is over,
we decided to book a Gig together and we
all were shirtless yammered on the
runway looking rip because we're gonna
lose shitloads of weight this month and
we all post.
That's fine.
Right?
Let's do this.
I'm really excited now.
How much,
what's the most amount of points you've
gotten in a month and a month?
Yeah,
I think it was right just under 4,500.
Forty 500 is a lot.
Yeah,
so the most I've seen somebody do with
seven.
Seven.
Oh,
that's crazy.
But that's like you're really,
really going after it all the time,
you know,
probably probably 30 days.
More than twice of what I did for 15
days.
Right.
[inaudible].
Yeah,
that's crazy.
That's a lot of work.
Oh,
here's the thing we didn't discuss
though.
So what's the bet?
What are the stakes?
What are we doing right?
What happens if you win?
What happens if you lose?
First of all,
it's just us because ours isn't even in
this bed.
He asked,
he goes,
well,
it goes.
My long walks.
We couldn't stop giggling because I'm
like pictured already shirtless in New
York with a chest strap on it.
Fuck yeah,
he's.
He's,
I think he's going to be San hope
called me and said he wanted to do it.
I can do this though.
Yeah.
He's not going to do this and he's also
not going to.
He's like sober octoberish I can't go
off everything or I'll have a stroke.
Will nest that.
He can't go off everything.
He just can't go off of the meeting is
actually going to a doctor this week and
he's going to get himself checked out.
Which is a rare thing is stan hope.
I don't know if you know those stand up
is sort of a policy to not go to the
doctor and when it breaks he dies.
Yeah.
That's his idea.
His idea didn't want Mris,
doesn't want diagnosis,
doesn't want recommendations,
doesn't want prescriptions.
He is going this week.
He's going to go this week to get
himself checked out to make sure that he
can go.
So I think,
I mean,
as much as Stan hope is sort of a
fatalist and he loves being this lovable
drunk and I can't feel good to just
always be drunk,
it just can't feel good.
I don't know.
He's taken time off before I.
I know he's taken time off before
smoking as well.
I know he quit smoking for quite a while
at one point in time.
I think he would like to be healthier,
you know?
I mean I know he would.
He would have more energy.
I think it would make his comedy better.
I really do not.
This comedy is not amazing.
It is.
But I just think you'd have more energy
know energy is a big thing.
So I think and I also think he's
something to do and connects them to us.
He's out there and fucking bumfuck
Bisbee Arizona out with a bunch of dorks
there.
I like,
I like partying as fuck you like
partying anywhere.
Yeah.
You do party in North Korea.
You fuck the out.
The invites out there.
I hope to God.
Somebody just puts us in front of him.
Encrypted email.
They go,
Kim,
this,
and then I want you to watch a machine
story,
and then he watches and he goes,
ah,
let's make another one.
Let's make.
I've had,
I've had moments where that where people
go,
we could get you into some trouble and I
got fucking scared.
I was with a group in Tanzania.
They were like,
we're going to go kidnap a baby elephant
if you're into it.
I was mad.
Damn Dude.
Kidnap a baby elephant.
Yeah.
Another tribe.
Kidnap this elephant sanctuary and they
get the kid back and the Messiah was
going into kidnap back and I was like,
part of me is like,
if you get a little bit of a buzz I'm
in,
but that was just.
Sounds like a good way to die.
Yeah.
Good.
Instagram video.
It's all about the insta stories.
The um,
I have the time to do those instastories
because it does not interfere with
actual life.
Like how,
how often are you present in real life
when you're doing.
I look at your dots on your instastory
and like Jesus,
there's like 70 dot.
No,
I don't ever put that many.
I put up,
I'll probably put up 10 a day.
That's the same thing.
Yeah.
What's up?
It's not mine or yours might be mine.
Why is it beeping?
Do I take it off of this?
Having it hanging like that,
but sometimes it'll just do it anyways,
but yeah,
it's fine like that for working out.
If it beeps.
One beat means it's on that three beat
means I shut all the beeps off on the
APP so I could use it in yoga class.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I don't want it to beep.
And of course,
you know.
Yeah.
You know,
you can wear those sensors right if you
want it to like make,
get a good reading to start.
It worked out great.
It was good.
I look at instastories,
I look at instagram as part of business.
Start me again.
Fucking thing's annoying.
Uh,
you looked at as part of business.
Part of my business and so I go,
I am very present in life.
I don't,
it's the story,
everything,
but like in moments like when the rat
runs into our house,
I definitely learned the story that I
always have my phone on me.
It's in my pocket.
I like how you're like,
I'm very present.
And then right before we started you're
like,
I'm terrible at this at home.
That was not a good parent.
I'm taking care of my kids by myself,
my wife somewhere traveling abroad.
It all these dots,
Bro.
That ain't 10 dots like this one.
What the fuck are you on?
Three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
eight dots.
Yeah,
it looks like more.
I said I love the school with a bag of
rice,
but it's only 1:00
PM and you have eight dots already
summer from last night and yesterday
it's 24 hours.
Okay.
But yeah,
I,
I'm,
I'm parenting by myself.
I can't do,
I'm not good at it.
I,
it's,
it's a good chance to bond with your
kids.
It is.
Or they realize exactly how out of touch
you are with their lives.
Well,
um,
I'm not one for giving parental advice,
but what I would say to do is abandoned
all other things you do while you're
doing it.
So think of yourself as like a mom,
like a house mom,
like instead of like trying to squeeze
it in with all the other shit you do,
you won't be good at it if you do that.
If,
when I,
if,
if my wife goes somewhere and I have to
just take care of my kids.
I don't do anything else.
I schedule nothing,
nothing else.
If I do a podcast,
I have to do it during the day while the
kids are at school and then once there I
don't go to,
I don't do shows that night.
I don't do shit.
I just hang out with them and we do
shit.
Make sure I do take them to a pottery
class.
So we'll go to a fucking Dojo.
Boom.
One of those bouncy places.
They have trampolines and shit.
Dude.
Just do stuff with them and leave your
phone off,
leave your phone off.
Your kids are there.
Unless unless you want your wife to
contact you,
maybe that,
but don't look at your twitter,
just hang out with them.
It's um,
it's,
you have to like have like rules in your
head.
My kids are a lot older kids though.
Yeah.
But still you want to interact with them
and no matter how old they are,
I know.
But your kids are still young.
Minor,
minor,
like 14 and 12 and so yeah.
But don't you hang out with them and do
stuff?
Last night we watched deadpool.
Cool.
We're going out to dinner tonight.
Perfect.
Yeah,
but just the actual getting up,
I was telling Tom I got up at 5:45
to get,
make them breakfast and,
and my daughter,
my oldest daughter had already pulled
the trash out,
put it by the door,
back door for me to take out.
Was literally gave me a speech and I was
like,
just so you know,
you need to be ready to go at 5:45.
Like you can't just get up at 5:45
and kind of like slow roll into the
morning.
I'm at school a C,
they've got to be.
She got to be at school at eight I
think,
but it's usually lecturing you,
Dr.
I said,
but and leanne was loving it.
Leanne calls.
He's like,
yeah,
you got to get going.
You can't just get up and be regular
burger,
your daddy on duty.
Got I.
I made the mistake of saying I was going
to make pancakes and everyone was like,
you can't,
you don't have time to make pancakes.
And I was like,
guys,
if I'm going to make pancakes,
I'm making pancakes.
I've got the standard batter storage and
they're like,
we need something else.
We're already hungry.
We've got to go.
And so yeah,
we're on a schedule with Lianza gangster
with that shit.
I just,
when you phoned me into her life,
my brain doesn't work like that.
Right?
Yeah.
I get that.
But it's like when you're just hanging
out with them,
just them.
It's a,
you've got to realize is.
I mean it's for everyone that has kids,
just you only have a few of these years.
You know,
you only,
you only have a few and then next thing
you know,
they're adults.
It happens quick.
Yeah.
So 14.
What happened overnight?
You know,
I have friends that don't have good
relationships with their kids and weird.
It's weird to see that sucks.
Sucks.
It's weird to see kids that are
resentful,
angry at you.
You got that comment?
For sure.
Right?
Is that coming?
No.
Teenagers is tough,
man.
It is tough there.
Well,
first of all,
being a teenager's fucking tough.
You gotta like remind them over and over
again.
You're dealing with a term called
downpour of hormones that you just don't
know what to do with.
You remember what that was like?
Yeah.
You're so confused all the time.
Confused bodies in fucking disarray for
you.
It's probably exacerbated by like them
being like this generation then knowing
that you're racist.
Fucking trunk and racist.
And then the crossfit people are
picketing outside your house.
What are our steaks?
So that haven't worked.
Okay.
So the most you've ever,
the most you've ever gotten is um,
so what did I,
what did I get today?
200 or something like that.
What did I get to 11 to 11.
That's a normal workout for me,
right?
I think 200 is like a is a good strong
workout.
Yeah.
So good.
Normal workout.
So if you get 200,
well if I did 200 twice a day,
Jesus men,
how many days a week you plan on doing
that?
I'm going hard son.
I'm trying to kill Bert.
I'm in.
I'm in for the challenge.
Yeah,
I mean I want you to say that Mickey
Mantle genes.
Real well.
Shit.
You did the UVA.
You just heard what he's doing.
I know and I understand that.
I have that.
I have the accessibility to get there.
I'm,
I'm up for the challenge.
But you're planning on Joe,
you're planning on trust.
Yeah,
but you're actually planning a 400
points a day.
You're running six days a week,
let's say,
or what?
Yeah,
at least.
Yeah.
I might go seven,
seven days a week.
So how about I lose 400 points a day?
Can
I do different things?
That's true.
That's the key to it.
We put an 8,000
points.
You're close to it.
I want to try to pretty close to eight.
That's the only thing is I have a
hunting trip that's going to take me
away for six days.
I have a cruise that's t to take me away
for five,
but when I think of Bobby Kelly's going
to.
When I'm doing the hunting trip,
like I'll put.
I'll send this to you jamie.
You see what I'm like.
A typical day in the mountains is like
when you're.
That's some of the most brutal workouts
I've ever done because you're hiking at
altitude and when you're at altitude
man,
it's fucking.
I did 12 miles a day.
Thirty 1000 steps.
Shit.
One hundred and 16 floors at 8,100
feet.
Well,
just so you know,
if like if you wore it,
that's a.
that's a typical day in the mountains
hunting.
If you wore it by the way for that,
you would just,
you know,
it would come out to some crazy number.
How many steps did you say?
I mean that's 31,000
steps.
Twelve,
12 miles in the mountains,
but it's the thing is the elevation
you're going up and down hills and
stepping over logs and you're always,
always breathing heavy.
It's rough.
Are you going to wear it for that?
Fuck Ya.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Fuck,
I guess I'm running another marathon.
I mean that's working out.
You want me to run around that Goddamn
cruise ship?
So 120,000
points a year.
A month would be.
You know,
you can't get them any points left.
There's no way.
What are you talking to them when were
talking to 8,000
at the most.
Like he said,
he said 4,500
was his best.
His best month and that's crazy.
That was working out like probably 22 or
23 days and doing,
you know,
something like 200 plus points each
time.
That's amazing.
Okay,
so 8,000
is redeemable.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Okay.
Your best.
Most 4,000
now the without like being in a
competition.
I've hit 43,
4,400
let's say.
Okay.
Joe Immediately would get 6,000
if you just did what you did today.
Everyday.
At this month you can just do it if I
did it every day every year,
but that was just the morning workout
today.
But we're all doing to a dose.
I got this recognized school here.
We got to have someone call the fucking
rock so we know we're going to stay on
this and this makes me more excited than
anything.
Yeah,
no,
it's good.
It's good to challenge whatever it is.
Listen,
we should all come in even and just make
red pay for everything was never going
to.
He's never gonna catch up to big shout
out our.
I mean our,
we've said it before,
but he really did come through on that
bet.
He did.
I'm saying um,
when he took us to the game,
he bought crazy tickets and I thought
they were much less.
He gave us a first class experience.
Nice.
And um,
we should make them do it again.
Yeah.
Like what would be the stakes go?
It's gotta be.
It's gotta be something that we can all
participate in.
Floyd Mayweather.
Manny Pacquiao to Ooh,
that's a great one.
Front row we're talking about.
Yeah.
By the way,
by the way,
say whatever you want about me being on
my phone the entire time.
I have the best fucking video from that
of the last,
the last them scoring a touchdown
videotape,
the touchdown,
and they cut to Tom and are a nice.
Yeah,
no,
it's great.
That was a really fun fucking weekend.
That was dude.
Pick.
That place is going.
That's where Larry,
the cable guy performs.
Oh my God.
Fucking places like that.
It's so big.
As audiences are winds,
floyd mayweather,
Pacquiao.
I don't know.
I think it's in December.
Is it in December?
Yeah,
definitely.
It might be in Japan though,
into.
This might be a day of a book to get.
So I don't know.
There's talk that it might be their
guys.
Oh,
let's go to that in Japan.
That sounds crazy,
but it also.
That's like asking a hundred grand.
We're not flying.
Coach are not flying coach.
She lost.
There's no way
he could win.
Right?
So someone has to someone else to win.
But more importantly one person is going
to lose.
Oh.
So like if you beat me and I beat you,
that don't mean shit because we're all
beating Ari.
Right?
It's like a skins game.
He's already,
but you know,
he's going to be like,
I'm not
doing the fucking point.
Maybe,
but maybe he's listening to us right
now.
He's stewing.
Should we call him?
He's getting angry and he's sober,
which Mike might do even more.
I was like,
fuck you.
I'm going to win.
We're going to fucking win.
What if red goes crazy?
Fucking goes whole hog every day.
Six hours a day.
Takes spin classes and crossfit classes
and whereas it,
during Jujitsu,
floyd mayweather,
his planet come back in Tokyo before his
rematch with Mandy.
This was a couple weeks ago.
So.
Oh,
so he wants a tune up fight.
Huh?
I might not be real.
Yeah.
Might that be?
I'm,
you know,
would you go to that?
You have to go to the fight though.
Yes.
It'd be an interesting fight.
I mean,
they're both past their prime,
but it will be a fun event too.
Yeah.
But I mean was just knocked out.
Lucas,
PTSA and floyd hasn't fought in a year
since he beat conor Mcgregor,
but that's not a real box.
I mean it's a boxing match,
but it's on a boxing match at an elite
level.
Like if it was,
if he was boxing terrence Crawford or
someone who's like at the very top now,
he's not in that kind of zone right now,
but he's still the best ever.
It if not the one of assurance of the
greatest boxers in the history of the
world ever.
You know,
no question.
What we should do is tear the tear of
the winnings.
Okay.
First place pays for nothing.
Whole weekend.
I liked this idea.
Second pays for their pace,
for their tickets to whatever is least
expensive,
pays for their ticket and nothing else.
Third place plays for a.
all hotels are saying tear it off,
so that's the last place.
Just pays the most out,
but he's not.
He's not dropping so forth.
Twenty grams in the last place.
Person has to cover flights,
but they can use their miles.
See,
the problem is res bets are like,
no,
no.
The loser has to wear a beard of my
pubes and he's got a.
he's got to clean his face with his
fucking all of his suggestions.
So psychotic,
drink all of our pis and I really am
solid over my shoulder.
She goes,
no,
you were not drinking.
Everyone's pissed.
He said,
he's like,
you got to do a panhandler for six hours
on the radio.
She was a homeless guy who was like,
I'm into that already.
But yeah,
he's,
yeah.
He wanted us to do really ridiculous
shit,
like down the street naked.
The tears of paying for it.
So it's not all.
It's a good idea.
Right?
So one person doesn't take the whole
beating.
First place pays nothing all week.
That's true.
The first place should be.
I don't cover the first place.
You'd get like a belt.
We should make a belt.
Sure.
October belt.
A real one.
Like a real,
real wild.
Like a wwe.
Yeah.
Oh,
October,
October.
Belt Champ,
champ.
Jamie,
I need.
This is a project I need you to look up
where you would get a pro wrestling
belt.
Not Know knockoff shit.
No,
no.
Nice one.
Oh God.
I just got.
I just found my inner voice when I work
out that fucking belt.
Just.
Oh my God,
I'm so excited.
Inner Voice.
So you're going to start doing your two
days,
but I might be doing three days.
Wow.
Looking at him.
Looking at me.
Serious.
He's excited now,
Dude.
Oh,
now tell him he ain't shit and there's
no way he'll win this firearm up even
more.
Tell me I can't run a marathon.
You can definitely ran the marathon,
but there's no way you'll win this
though.
There's no way.
Oh Wow.
Tommy's got reverse psychology.
We can get a pepsi belt.
Who the fuck wants a Pepsi Belt?
I know a guy.
He's diabetic.
So what?
Which we have on the uh,
is that me up on the right there?
I think it's a bearded gentleman bell.
Okay.
So we found a company that makes belts.
What's the name of his company?
Belts.com.
Okay.
So we need some sort of a logo.
We need sober.
October is definitely the name of it,
right?
The sober October belt and undisputed
sober Ciobo champ.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
What should we have on it?
Still?
Okay.
I should be our faces engraved in it.
Should it be like the,
like the no smoking sign?
No boost sign.
No pills,
no needles,
no need to get on the sides.
Yeah.
Good with needles,
piles
of coke.
And then guy tried to suck his own dick
and we'll just tell everyone it's yoga.
Yeah.
So we'll have to come up with how long
does it take to make one of these belts
month?
Let's find out.
Hey listen,
whoever pro-am belts,
if you're listening.
Three to four weeks.
Oh fucking fun.
So if we finished the design by the end
of this week,
we might be able to have it at the end
of the month.
You might be holding up that build up
the house.
I feel great.
You definitely want to be holding up at
all.
I'll definitely either me or joe
flights.
Lodging tickets.
Mrs.
Missing you.
There's no way.
Forty $500 maybe you've never worked out
with them.
I've worked out with them.
What happens?
Oh,
he gives up.
He used to work out together.
Done like hotel,
like pre before we did.
Actually we went,
when we were in Phoenix,
we went to a like an MMA gym.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
We did.
We worked out.
Yeah.
I tell him.
I used to go to Barry's bootcamp
together.
What happened?
I,
I don't mind throwing up if I work out.
Like I like I ended up like,
you enjoy it.
I do because I know that I've done it as
hard as I can do it.
I get it.
I've thrown up before a girl came into
my green room this weekend and threw up
all.
I thought she was looking for the
bathroom and just fucking throw up.
I'm like,
that's your kind of crowd.
I started throwing up,
by the way,
your pr,
your Promo you showed me.
It's going to bring in more vomiters.
I cut a promo.
I'm doing.
It'll be dropping next Monday.
We're announcing my tour next week,
but uh,
I cut a promo hurling.
No,
no,
no.
It's just what it's like being at one of
my shows and just fucking chaos.
It's chaos.
Yeah.
Well your shows or chaos.
You,
you're not doing just a comedy show.
You've got like a whole Party experience
happening.
We got mean stand up and stand up
straight,
stand up.
And then a lot of times I do a meet and
greet people get to talk and hang out.
I think as a fan I liked that.
So I do that.
And then a lot of times at the end of
the night and a lot of times I go,
I'll be at the bar next door and uh,
everyone goes to the bar.
Those are fucking crazy.
Do you think you can do that when the
crowds get to like 3000,
$4,000?
Of course not.
I don't know.
I actually had a real loose,
had conversation about what meet and
greets are going to look like on this
theater tour because I don't want to get
rid of the meet and greet.
So it means it as silly as it sounds,
but I think it means something for them
to hang out does.
And I don't want to charge 100 bucks for
a meet and greet,
but I definitely can't do 1200 people
like I did when I did the Wilbur.
I told everyone to go meet me at the bar
next door and it was fucking chaos.
I mean it was like,
oh,
like literally elbow to assholes and I
just was not,
I didn't get to hang out with anyone.
I was just taking pictures over and over
and over.
So I want to try to figure out some
workaround for a meet and greet for this
theater tour.
Because Dude,
when I go to Scandinavia,
I want to meet to meet podcasts.
You know,
one thing that annoys me,
those pictures where
people have stacks of pictures they want
you to sign and the sound that is not,
does not like take a picture with me.
That's not,
will you sign this from my friend that's
not sign this for me.
That's like you're asking me to work.
And they fucking shame.
And they go,
they come out with the one that,
hey,
we sent.
You Go,
oh yeah.
And then the sixth behind it come to the
site and they're like,
and this and this and this and this.
Some guy,
the other day I had 30.
Yeah,
whoa.
they,
they've,
they've run into you at the airport and
there's like six dudes and they have
stacks like,
hey man,
you're,
you're showing up and you want me to
work.
This is what you're doing.
You want me to stop what I'm doing?
And you think it's only,
it's only five minutes of your time.
Yeah,
that's true.
But you're not really a fan.
You're just a guy trying to get me to
work for sure.
This is,
you signed them.
I signed one.
I'll say I'll sign one,
I'll sign one.
And they get mad.
Like some guy got mad and philly
remember that dude got upset.
He's famous.
And I was like,
you're not a fan.
You just told me you're not a fan.
He told me.
He literally told me,
he's like a huge.
You don't even sell.
Well he goes,
you're so full,
like $7.
I go,
I don't give a fuck what they sell for
my autograph.
I go,
I said,
don't,
don't show up at the airport and
harassed me.
Then I,
I'll sign one.
Do you do a meet and greet?
You used to do meet and greet tonight.
I used to do.
I'll still do that,
but I used to do meet and greets at the
Chicago theater for 3,700
people.
I would wait and take photos with
everybody,
but you can't do it anymore.
People go too crazy as the podcast got
crazier and crazier.
People go crazy and they were hold on
your arm and want to tell you how you
changed their life and want to tell you
like long stories.
I'm like,
look,
there's 500 people behind you waiting.
I can't give you 15 minutes here.
I can give you five minutes.
I just,
it just got too strange and it just got
too many people wanting to get on the
podcast like you got to get me on.
I'm going to tell you my story about
beating drug addiction.
Like I'm sure it's a great story.
I can't get you on a stop.
This is not how this works.
You know?
There's just too much of that,
too much.
It's not.
If it was just high,
I want to take a picture.
I had a good time.
Great.
But it's not that.
Then it's all these agenda driven people
that all want to do things and they
want,
they want you to do things for them.
They think there's too many people that
have been on the podcast,
just regular folks and then they get on
the podcast and now people know about
them and so a lot of people think like,
Hey,
if I just got on the podcast,
that would make my career totally,
you know,
whether they're a singer or they have a
book or this,
it just gets too annoying.
It's just,
it's too overwhelming.
But the meet and greet is actually like
it's part of your brand,
I feel like,
like,
seriously.
Yeah,
definitely.
It's like when we did,
we did the Chicago theater run with
Macondo and nate and all those guys.
Yeah.
Know,
just um,
I uh,
like it.
None of the,
none of the guys wanted to do meet and
greet and I.
There was like a thousand people waiting
outside the theater and I thought,
I just thought,
but that's different because that's who
I am.
Like if I go see a band I am,
I am like super compelled to go talk to
them and tell them how great I thought
they were.
Part of that is who I am.
And so I went out and did pictures with
everyone waiting in the alley at the
Chicago theater and I was like.
And then when someone goes,
dude,
you have no idea.
I love the podcast.
I love Tommy.
I love the weight loss.
I beat,
you know,
I love that interaction.
I remember one time I was in Scotland
and I was like,
I just hit it out.
Hey,
is anyone any fans when you go have a
beer with me?
And these three guys showed up and it
was right when bobcat was on your
podcast and we just bullshitted about
bobcat appearance.
We'd all listen to it.
So,
you know,
I think I,
but I don't know what I'd like to maybe
charge only like weed out the people
that don't want to,
you know.
Yeah.
But see there's the problem,
I'm not,
I'm philosophically opposed to making
people pay for pictures and making
people pay to hang out with you.
I just don't think it's right.
But there should be a way to like just.
Yeah,
but there's this thin the herd is a
thing unless you
charged money or pick people.
So like there's a company now that does
that.
They do these vip things and someone
brought it up to me and like you could
make this.
I'm like,
I'm not doing it.
And they go,
but you could make someone stop.
I'm not doing it.
I mean I used to do it for free forever.
I stopped doing it because too many
people got too weird.
But I'm not going to charge people.
I'm just not going to do it.
But I know a lot of fucking people that
do a lot of people and they make a lot
of money doing it.
You used to do it right?
What the ingredient?
Yeah.
I used to also feel like,
you know,
honestly like I,
I like meeting people.
I a people on the street and meet them
when I walk out of the back of the
venue.
I always,
there's people there.
I always meet people,
but I just don't.
I don't,
I'm not that good at the meet and greet.
I'm just not that comfortable with it.
I don't like it that much.
The is definitely not.
I mean,
in not being shitty,
but it's not you.
You're not like,
I'm not very social people that there's,
there's people that are demanding and
they're like,
oh,
you don't love your fans because it's
not true extra thing from now.
No,
no,
no.
Here's the arrangement.
The range of Nez.
I work hard on my act.
I do a lot of sets.
I prepare.
Take the show very seriously.
Uh,
come to town.
I try to do a kick ass show.
That's the arrangement.
Thank you.
Goodnight.
Are Our deals done?
And now if you think that you have to
tell me some fucking life story for 20
minutes or I'm not your friend.
Like,
no,
this is not the arrangement.
This is not like you're demanding too
much and you're also not aware of how
many other people would want to do the
same thing.
Like it would be impossible.
It's just,
it's untenable.
You can't do it.
There's too many.
I would say that for me,
like anybody who wants to wait outside
that door,
I'll meet anybody to.
She fucked up.
Son shouldn't have said that.
That was a mistake that they're not
going to wait.
They're coming right now.
There was one thing.
They have a little trailer out there
right now.
Tom's a
or so it's amazing that we're friends
because we're so very different.
Men.
Uh,
there was once a comment on his
instagram that made me laugh so hard
compared to my comments.
It was a,
Hey Tom,
I'm really sorry for looking at you at
the airport.
They said,
I'm sorry.
I said,
Hi Heidi with the airport.
Yeah,
but it's just Tom's face just like he
is.
He's not needy.
That's what it is.
And so when some guy said,
hi Tom on high,
and then the guys didn't know what to
say,
I walked away.
Ah,
he,
he came out.
I still remember it.
I was Atlanta airport.
He came over as I was about to take the
escalator at,
at Hartsfield Jackson and he,
he goes,
Hey,
I'm a big fan.
Like,
oh hey man.
And it was like a quick thing and he was
like,
big fan.
I go,
thanks a lot.
Appreciate it.
Got on the son.
Never thought twice.
And then he wrote,
I'm sorry that I bothered you at the
airport.
And I was like,
you didn't bother me at all.
It was just,
that's just someone who's trying to get
a reaction from you.
He's not really sorry.
And also there was nothing to be sorry
for,
you know,
I felt he was like,
he just wants to keep it going.
Right.
I'm sorry,
don't be sorry.
Can I hang out with you?
Right.
But Bert.
Yeah.
No one would ever apologized.
I was at the,
I was at the hotel,
did Bella tours going on this weekend in
San Jose and so it was all fucking
fighters.
Right.
I ran,
I ran into Jay big John McCarthy.
Oh,
okay.
The elevator.
What a great guy.
Great Guy Too.
He was like,
I knew who he was,
but I didn't want to.
Like I was afraid I just working out and
he was like a.
It was like,
hi.
I just got done working out and I was
like,
yeah,
I wouldn't want to bother me because we
have a mutual friend.
And I was like,
does he know who I am?
He was like,
Joe Rogan.
And I went,
I know exactly who the fuck you are.
And then,
uh,
but a big cock speak fellow.
No,
no,
John,
that's a different guy.
I'm sure John has a big dick to moose
kind of fucking the hammer.
When did you see Musashi deck in the
fucking sauna?
You saw his dick,
dude.
It was legit.
Of course he called me about it because
I didn't see it
fight because the fights on some new
streaming thing called dayson that it's
called the zone they have.
But then the name is with Michael
Buffer.
It's pretty good.
They have a commercial about how dumb.
How do you spell it?
D,
a c,
n the zone and it's about.
He's joking about.
I noticed soon.
It's called the zone yet,
what's called what?
But it's not zone.
There's no.
Oh Hey man.
He can't change how people pronounce
things phonetically.
That's stupid.
So I'm probably made it and it got
stuck.
Well,
a blue saucy just beat the shit out of
Rory Macdonald.
Stopped him in the second round.
I didn't even get a chance to see it
because I thought it was going to be on
TV and so I went to check my Bella tour
on my dvr and it wasn't even there,
but he beat him with his Dick.
Pick it.
I don't know how I got to cut weight
without cooking hog on it.
Wow.
That's.
I want to see that footage now.
How big?
A 10 inches.
I'll tell you what it is.
It's bigger than this.
Fat,
fatter than a water bottle.
I'll tell you right now.
No certain point in time you dick
becomes a liability when it's as fat as
a water.
I don't
know what.
I don't know how we brought that into
the ring with him.
Like every girl needs probably
unsatisfied.
Totally.
As soon as they pull it out,
they're like,
hold on a second,
get out of here out.
And he's like,
he's always one 72.
He was weighed one 72 that day because I
got on the scale after he did know he
weighs more than that.
He fights it one 85.
He cuts wait to get to one 85.
He used to be a light heavyweight
champion,
so he used to be fighting it maybe a
little too.
The thing wrong,
maybe it looks at the school and I think
the scale was off because I said I'm
going to say this now that I said that
once you weighed one 95 to 30,
something could make one 72.
He would destroy everyone in the
welterweight division.
He's a murderer.
Is that how you say his name?
Big Gardens.
Saucy.
I thought it was Gerald mean dyslexic
person.
Nope,
I'm dyslexic.
So one of the things when I read things,
I don't see it right away.
He's a monster man.
He's one of the big losses for the UFC
because in my opinion is one of the top
two or 385 pounds in the world at the
UFC had beaten Chris Weidman and then he
goes over and fights in beltour now,
but apparently they just came up with
some large cash.
They're trying to get big names over
there either.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know anything about UFC is no
hammer me about that,
but like do tours really cool.
Just being down there.
It was like Chael Sonnen,
rampage Jackson,
like fifty cent was there.
It was like a really like,
uh,
if,
if you're a passer by failure of mma,
then you're like,
oh,
shut the fuck up.
They're doing really good fights.
They have big.
They have big talent there.
Now they have Michael Chandler who's one
of the top light weights in the world.
Rory Macdonald is one of the best,
if not the best welterweight in the
world.
He's definitely top two or three.
He's beaten.
Tyron Woodley,
who's the UFC champion,
who I think is the best rory.
They snagged over them right?
They snagged him,
they have underlay.
Silva is that habit vandelays way past
his prime and so his rampage,
you know those guys,
they,
they're doing the legends tour and
rampage just knocked out family,
but vandelay doesn't look good anymore
and they should let them choose.
Let them choose.
But you know,
they're doing a great job.
They're doing a great job.
They're really,
they're promoting these fights well.
They're putting on and the welterweight
division they have.
Douglas Lema was one of the best in
world.
They have a Paul Daley who can knock out
any living human being.
They have Lorenz Larkin.
Fifty cent was given away a cash prize.
Hazers Trey Whoa.
Got into the steam room.
Was fifty cent.
What does it has to award Bella tour?
What does it say?
Welterweight Grand Prize winner.
A million dollar cash prize.
Didn't he just go bankrupt?
50 of this part of a deal he had with
the get the strap brand,
which I guess he owned,
owned and sold.
And part of that money is going into
this.
A million dollars goes to give the
person a million dollar cash prize.
So the welterweight grand prixs that
they had koresh cough,
just fought Lima.
Those two guys are excellent to Koresh.
Cough is another top 10 guy in the world
I think.
And he's fighting for Bella to Lima,
beat him.
Lima and rory had a great fight.
Rory beat Lima by decision.
So there's Rory Douglas,
Lema,
Paul Daley,
and still to this day like Paul Dale,
he can knock out anyone.
He's so fucking dangerous.
A puncher I'll just do is.
He's got a left hand that's just a
nuclear missile.
So.
And he just knocked out Lorenz Larkin,
who is also a top welterweight.
There's so many good fighters over there
now.
There's so many good fighters in
general.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's A.
MMA is coming up right now.
I mean there's the top talents.
This fucking fight this weekend between
Mcgregor and Khabib.
Gunmen off is going to be crazy.
That is a crazy fight.
That's Vegas,
right?
Yup.
That is a fucking crazy.
Because on that.
Yup.
I don't know what the fuck's going to
happen.
Are you excited?
Yeah.
I don't want to lose that.
I wish I wasn't going on this cruise.
I would totally hit you up for tickets
yet man.
I'm super excited.
Speaking of which on this,
on this bet,
this is just.
Do you think you can get us free tickets
to like so we can take that out of the
cash prizes because that would really
want to go where I send you free tickets
for the UFC.
Do you think they do.
I think we could leverage you to get us
tickets to a boxing match for sure.
We can get some tickets as opposed to
putting that all except I.
That may make the prize right.
If it's.
If it's like,
you know.
Right.
So
maybe I'll get the tickets for the
fight.
I'll use leverage to get the tickets and
then we'll make a big deal that we're
going to go and then we'll get like
sweets at some hotel somewhere and the
loser has to pay for like some
extravagant meal.
And
hold on.
We got flights and lodging.
I'm going to be on the bat and then.
And then
private,
private jet.
That's the way to do it.
What are we going to Vegas?
Yeah,
if it's a.
If it's fun,
I don't wanna go to Tokyo for some
fucking stupid fight.
Yeah,
let's go private debt.
Private jet into Vegas because he's
talking about fighting this guy that's
not manny Pacquiao in Tokyo.
He's not talking about fighting Manny
Pacquiao,
fight Manny Pacquiao.
He's going to fight him in Vegas.
That's where the real money is.
You're going to end up spending a lot of
money.
Should we get matching so you think
you're going to lose?
No,
I'm not gonna lose.
There's no way to win the whole thing.
I think you're going to come in like if
it's your fantasy that you come in at
the end and you win the whole thing.
Cinderella story should work out with me
once he killed those fantasies.
I want to know.
I learned to what you think you're going
to get.
Do it.
I've got a page of numbers right here.
Okay.
What do you think is going to want to
unfriend you now so that you can't see
my track?
So you should see mine.
Yours is scaring me.
I know what I have to do now when I go
home tonight.
So wait,
let me understand,
what do you think you're going to get?
Because I want to know what do you think
you're going to get because you're good
at calling the shots.
So.
Well Tom has already achieved more in a
day then my first workout.
You've already achieved 2:30,
you said it was the most
most I've ever done in a day is three 83
$80 a day.
Yeah.
Is that two a day?
Wow.
Actually I'm sorry it's more than that.
Three 80 in one workout.
But that was.
But that was,
how did you do that?
Seven miles and I did mostly uphill and
then I went around and like,
so it was a hike run,
right.
So sustained heart rate for for a long
period of time.
Oh you guys are fucked.
And when I wear this elk hunting so you
guys will never get.
I'll get $500 a day.
Oh,
you'll do more than that.
Actually.
You guys actually going on like top top,
top workout or like most single day.
Single Day on that day.
So you could do,
you know,
let's say a hike like that or run and
then go back and go like,
oh I want to get like another 100
points.
I'm going to go on this.
How long was this battery go for?
Long time.
Fully charged for a week.
Yeah.
Really?
I didn't charge mine for a second time
until after I had it for over seven
months for all skeptical people.
This is not a sponsor.
No.
We don't know anybody that works at this
company and I don't want.
We talked about it in text messages.
I said we should do this punk rock.
I don't want to.
We shouldn't do this.
We shouldn't have a company sponsor.
There's no.
We just.
This is a good metric.
System should product.
We're going to use it because of that.
And I don't want it.
I don't want him to sponsor us.
So this is non sponsored.
This is.
And if it's a piece of shit we're going
to get to say it's a piece of shit.
Yeah.
So just so
people fucking with corporate.
I like these side effects.
I like the part right now.
It's like,
Oh God,
I wish you do sponsor.
No,
I'll try and John wounds,
wounds,
Boser will fly me out to pick show song.
Yang is a nice place.
You know,
I do it for real.
If they hit me up and then I'd probably.
But why would you want to do that?
Why would you want to go to?
Oh No,
it's about the stories I like.
I like,
I like crazy stuff like that.
I think that's a good story is
definitely on brand.
Most single day workout a gets a new
suit.
Okay,
that's good.
And all three of us have to buy them a
new suit or you just texted what?
What'd you say?
How do I register this thing?
We got to fucking Pansy.
He means he's in.
He's in man.
Wow.
Ari's in two.
Okay.
Most single day gets to compete,
but he doesn't exercise.
Oh,
you know what's so great.
Most single days to shoot and we're
going to be in the best shape of our
lives so we get a skinny suit that will
never be able to wear again.
Yeah,
we should write.
He has to email them for facility code.
It's easy.
They get it.
They'll send it right away.
You're right.
We should wear suits to the gig.
Yeah.
Oh,
I've never even had a suit.
Alright.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what we'll do.
I'll contact David August.
Are the guys who make my suits.
You suits.
Yeah,
I know David.
August.
Yeah.
They make awesome suits made.
It's got like a little bit of flex to
it.
So if you're built like a troll like me,
he can move around in these things.
There's a flex around their belly.
Yes.
Everything.
What's that?
Thomas got a suit guy.
You got a suit guy?
Yeah.
But David is.
Yeah,
he makes conor Mcgregor's when Tom got
his fat suit with Chad,
Chad Daniels and God and they went and
got suits.
Does that it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
There was a documentary called I need
you to kill that I'm in,
which it's on Amazon prime and there's a
scene
in the documentary where we go and we
get a suits made and um,
yeah,
the,
I go with chat and it's really,
really fun man.
I mean,
yeah.
I went to the same district that Ari got
his maiden and that Guy Danny,
I went to Danny.
They always have like the names are
really sitting there like,
did you get yours at Joe's or Danny's
like,
that's the designers there.
Right,
so they do a great job,
man.
First place was for nothing,
so I can place a
most single day gets a brand new suit.
Should we do third place plays,
lodging.
Fourth place pays for flights and we fly
private.
I like it.
I like that man.
Are you going to have to pay for a
flight?
You're going to play lodging.
Yeah.
Right.
Second place has got to pay for
something.
What's second place,
but I said,
well,
who's got to pay for whatever?
The second dinner.
One big nowhere.
I don't know.
Lodging might be more than dinner.
Big Dinner.
We could ball the crazier dinner bottles
of wine for a thousand bucks.
You realize if I'm in,
Oh my God,
that won't get in panic because I know
that I'm going to be wanting to drink it
there.
I tell you about the dinner I went to
Ralphie with.
Ralphie may,
me and Ralph,
he went to dinner with our families.
This is one of my favorite stories.
We'd been.
We'd been partying all weekend.
And this is Hawaii?
No,
this is a Bahamas.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
But you got to set it up that at the
time you're like,
middling or just.
Yeah,
that was a feature act.
How many years ago is this a,
it's just leanna and his first trip away
from Georgia.
So it's from our daughter.
Ten years plus.
It's got to be at least 10,
10,
11 years.
You can actually find it if you can.
It's on my video because I posted a
video at that time.
So it's probably 2007 maybe before
trial.
What happened before I started birth to
conquer,
I was 37 years old.
Thirty six years old at the time.
Ralph,
he's killing it.
He's balling.
I'm headlining some maybe for like 1500
bucks.
2,000
I'm headlining and,
but I'm,
I'm still featuring at the time.
Um,
and so maybe I'd done jamison comedy
tours.
That was.
So I had a little bit of money,
but not much.
No money to speak of,
so we go to the do this Gig for Paul and
Young Ron and the first night there we
go out to eat and it's a huge dinner and
I'm like,
how much do I owe?
And I was like,
oh player,
you know,
I got that Bert Kreischer don't worry
about it.
You just,
you,
you only have a great weekend.
I said,
no,
I got to pay for.
So I'm like,
Nah,
don't even read your why when you're
wrapping around.
Moving around.
We May.
So we go out that night,
everyone goes drinking,
we have a great time.
The next night we go out to eat,
everyone goes out to eat and Ralphie
wants again.
I go to pay for when he goes,
oh,
playboy,
you know you don't mind is no good
around me.
Just come on.
We didn't have a good time.
We go do a show,
an amazing fucking show.
We'd go out drinking again.
Rafi picks up everything.
The last night there we go to Sushi at
Nobu and Leanne says,
you can't live off.
He pay.
You got to pick up the bill.
And I went,
okay,
so I go over to the lady before before,
um,
I'm going to screw up numbers,
I'll tell you that right now.
But I go over to the lady before the
bill comes and I go,
hey,
the big guys not paying,
here's my credit card.
She's like,
okay.
So we eat and I drink and we eat and I
drink.
And was getting like boats,
right?
Boats.
They're just like,
wow,
you know,
I mean they brought out 50 pieces who
she,
they're like a cool deaton,
dolphins and so,
and I am doing Saki bomb after Saki bomb
and the lady comes with the check and
it's like $2,000.
I did not have $2,000
and I did not.
I didn't have enough money to,
for the tip.
Like I didn't.
I was like,
why'd you think you could pay?
I didn't know what the bill would be.
I don't,
I've never paid attention to that stuff.
I didn't know what I just.
Do you ever eat out?
No,
but I,
I didn't,
I wasn't paying attention to what the
bill would be.
I thought it would be 500 bucks,
600.
I didn't know how expensive Sushi at
Nobu was that everything is through the
roof.
She puts the check in front of me and I
opened it up and I see it and I,
I immediately freeze and leanne goes,
how much is it?
And just instinctually go fuck you.
That's how much it is.
And she goes and Ralphie fucking fucking
our shit.
Gotcha.
I.
Then I go Ralph Ralph.
He goes,
don't worry player.
We go out and win it back.
So I go to our bank machine and I put a
thousand dollars and I go over and I put
it on black hits red,
$3,000
matter of minutes late.
Honestly,
snipes lied to you.
We,
Leanne won't speak to me is probably one
of the biggest fights we've ever been
in.
Were fighting in the lobby and I'm
hammered.
She's mad because you bet the extra
money.
No,
because I said fuck you.
That's how much it is.
Don't ever talk to me like you're my
partner.
We're team don't.
If I go,
I didn't know what to say in the moment.
I it was,
it was more money than we had at the
time that it was probably three weeks on
the road for me.
Of course.
And then you gambled away a thousand.
Like a fucking.
God said Mickey Mantle.
Gene.
Yeah.
That's not me.
That's loop
my favorite part of this.
It's just like,
you know that you got shamed,
you know.
That's what I love about it.
What,
what makes you feel good about that?
Just say it's my friend doing something
stupid.
I got to run.
Actually I do.
We haven't worked this out right now.
So we have to bring ren on this.
Right?
Because he can't,
can't have no say he couldn't be here
right now.
Right now.
Okay.
Call them up.
Yeah.
Let's see if he answers.
So what's we call at the same time.
He's.
I know he's answering.
Let's see.
Stingy.
Do you get them dry and got
do this fucking stupid thing.
Hey,
you're on speaker with Joe and Tom.
We can all hear you.
And we're doing.
You do not have consent to use my voice.
Hey,
we're talking about the bet.
Here's what we're thinking.
Right?
So with these mind zone,
a fitness trackers,
a joe did 200 today,
he's planning on doing two days.
So we're thinking the person who gets
the most,
most calories,
most points burnt in a week.
It doesn't have to pay for anything out
of this challenge.
Okay.
Running away from
everything.
Got a murder.
My agents now calling shit.
No.
So the bet is we're going to go away
from.
We're fighting.
We're going to a fight in Las Vegas.
Okay?
Joe Thinks he can get on your fucking
agent.
Don't be scared.
I don't know how to.
There we go.
Here we go.
First place you'll have to pay for
nothing.
Second place would have to pay for.
We're thinking maybe one meal.
Third place will have to pay for
lodging.
Just let me fucking finish.
Third base will play for lodging.
Fourth place.
Oh,
play for
we finished.
I don't know.
I don't know the terms are talking
about.
So you've given me all the details or
something.
I don't understand.
What you're doing is telling them what
you're talking about.
And then give me the detail.
The person with the most fitness,
uh,
points points for the month.
We'll get in first place the person with
the second most fitness points for
second place and so on.
Now there's a bet going on and the prize
is going to a big fight,
a big boxing,
big boxing match in,
in Las Vegas.
There you go.
Yes.
First Place.
The person with the most fitness points
for the month will not have to pay for
one thing.
Second place.
Begging for change on the corner of
Lafayette Gun.
No Monica,
no pubic hair.
Beard.
I'm done with all of those.
Come on.
See?
I knew he would turn this into
humiliation.
We all,
we all come on the losers face.
So that's part of it.
The goblet fire
piss combined piss.
And I'm eating asparagus.
So Ari,
are you in?
Are you in on the bed?
I don't know if we're talking about
fruit
the weekend.
We have to figure out the weekend.
It's got to be a weekend.
Everyone can go.
Yeah,
we'll figure it out the weekend.
It's uneventful.
Tell him this.
Yeah,
but we're going to be high as fuck it.
It'll be fun and tell them this.
There's a belt involved.
Oh yeah.
The winter gets a belt championship
belt.
Sober October belt
and you're going to have to defend it
every year.
We're having it made and it's going to
have pills on it with a line through it.
Heroin on it with a line through it.
The guy stuck in his own right.
A boxing match.
Why don't we do something we don't want
to do.
We can.
We were going to go to see floyd
mayweather.
The rematch.
Mandy pack.
Yeah.
We don't have to do it though,
but it'd be fun.
Take place.
Nine years ago.
It would be fun to be in Vegas with like
a gentleman.
Yeah.
We're all together.
We don't have to work.
We're just all there to.
We're going to smoke cigars like a
fucking gentleman.
When did that happen?
I think it takes place sometime in
December,
but they haven't made the date.
They haven't made the date yet.
You're in December.
You're gone all December.
Were you going European?
You're up in Israel.
What if we go to a a good Bella tour
event?
Well,
I don't have to work.
You want to go see a an MMA event?
Why are you take off and go see the UFC
in the middle of this dance and we'll
get high there.
We'll do a bunch of heroin this down.
I came out.
I can't take off one.
I'll tell you one thing.
We can do one that I don't have to do
because I only do the big ones.
I don't do the ESPN ones and the.
Some of the ESPN ones are going to be
really big.
I could be in the audience for that.
Yeah,
let's do.
We can do that.
Okay.
Now we don't have to worry about
tickets.
Okay.
Alright.
The fourth place has to play for the
flight and we're flying private.
Yeah,
but just just to Vegas.
It's not a lot.
If it's Vegas event though,
I'm probably going to work at.
I'm going to be honest with you.
Okay.
So it's just we have to be like fucking
New York.
It's not that much.
Yeah.
Toronto.
We'll have to figure out where it is.
So are you the registered look,
we'll take care of that already.
I sent you an email if you email the
email,
I just sent you a text message.
If you emailed that address,
they'll send you a facility code right
away.
Some messaging.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It'll.
It'll just sink.
Sent an email to support at.
I sent you all the details to say I need
a facility code.
Did you buy yours on Amazon?
Yeah,
me too.
they didn't send me an facility code.
Are you in for a tiered financial bet
for a UFC event or joe doesn't have to
work and
humiliation.
Okay,
let's.
You know what?
Let's find it.
Let's find a sweet little spot of
humiliation in this for the last place.
Last place has got.
There's a punishment involved.
Got Drank piss.
Everybody's pissed.
Oh No,
no,
no goblet.
Oh No.
I know what you guys are fucking
friends.
Tommy.
They're like straight from the tap,
like a Yeti Tumbler.
Let's keep it warm.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hold on.
We're not really jre.
Tumbler.
Embow.
We'll rewrite the pis champion on it.
This right here.
We'll keep it.
Always keep it on this table,
so we'll know that the person drank the
other people's pissed.
I'd be like,
fucking forrest gump this month.
Why don't you guys just come on my back.
That fear factor?
I'll drink a gallon of piss.
Right?
You're not going to have to be the one
drinking piss.
Wouldn't either.
Tom or Ari.
I'm worried about my friend Ari.
He doesn't believe that you could ever
possibly witness this.
There's no way birtle even coming
fucking third there.
No Way.
What do you think of this?
Sorry.
Really for sure.
What?
You're going to a days and.
But what about,
what about burt's Mickey Mantle Gene?
Uh,
that would help them.
Or you're on the road a lot or no?
Yeah,
I'm on a cruise next year.
Oh,
that's good.
You can run on a boat.
I'm going to.
I'm trying to get burt to die.
Trying to keep up with me.
It is.
I'm doing four days.
Good luck.
Yeah,
you're afforded.
Okay.
Their corresponding.
Here's the important thing.
Let's see.
Something that we can all get behind.
What?
What,
what are you afraid of August.
The only problem with that is when we
got scheduled.
That's fine.
To do that though.
We can do that out and then we'll add.
We will come up with a and maybe this
will be fun.
We'll have a very tasteful yet
meaningful punishment for final for last
place.
Well tasteful.
You just.
You're at a [inaudible] wheelhouse.
Well,
he wants to be humiliating.
Frozen hot dog up your asshole.
That's what he's talking about.
He thought thought is too slippery and
break out.
We up until the end of April until the
innovative problem.
I really don't have any weeks open.
Well,
we could certainly do something at the
end of April.
We could figure it out.
Look,
yeah,
we'll figure that part of it out.
But you're in right?
You're in on the bed?
Yeah.
Okay,
so wait,
what's the.
The Bat,
his first place pays for nothing.
Second place pays for a meal.
Third place pays for lodging and fourth
place pays for a private jet.
Private jet.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
You're in,
you're in,
you're in what's wrong,
but that's part of what's humiliating.
Just don't pay so much money.
Just don't come in fourth.
Don't come in for it.
Enjoyed those long walks in the east
village.
Yeah,
those will definitely make you win four
years.
No,
I don't want to drive it yet.
What are you talking about?
Shut up.
Really interesting to bed on.
How about a helicopter money related.
It's cruise ship.
Winnebago across the country.
Why it got to be money related?
Well,
it just doesn't do anything.
Makes you feel terrible,
but we're all like.
The whole thing is that we're having fun
together and it's not supposed to be
like really wants you to suffer.
He wants you to drink is piss and
where's pubes on your face?
You got to get the names of the.
Of the three winters tattooed on your
left,
on your right hand,
on the inside palm of your right hand.
I'm not into that.
Yeah,
but I do like the belt.
I do like the fact that it's great.
We have to defend them.
Bell,
Michael Bell,
Jr.
Srovio a moving trophy every year.
KirSten,
who has the belt,
whoever wins,
they get to keep it in their house and
make videos.
It's very motivated.
Any idea,
all the social media or this social
media points,
you can get stand in front of that belt,
letting everybody know and tom will
finally have a belt of fits him.
So keep going.
So this is,
this has nothing to do.
So it's not about how many calories you
burn,
it's just about these weird points that
this thing made,
which is basically related to effort.
It's like effort points.
Yeah,
it's a good.
It's a good system.
Yeah,
you're incorrect.
Are you,
by the way,
by the way?
I don't,
I don't have any interest in going out
to vegas to go to la to get a private
jet to then go to vegas with you guys.
Okay.
What do you want to do?
What do you think it should be?
Uh,
some sort of humiliating thing or the
rest of it.
But liKe I would probably meet you guys
in vegas.
Wouldn't go to la then go to vega.
Tommy bonds has to leave.
We'll we'll sort this out,
but for sure there'll be a belt involved
for sure.
Begging,
begging for money on three,
not monica.
Yeah.
It's boring to us already.
How about this?
Can you agree on this tiered structure?
If we find an event that you are
comfortable and really excited about?
Yeah,
I'll do an event to go to.
It doesn't have to be.
I mean,
I think you have seen will be fun.
I've never seen the ufc fight,
but a tiered tiered structure of of
punishment.
Meaning for the bottom three,
a humiliation for number four.
Belt for the winter.
Single day.
By the way,
single day a calorie burn and the person
with the most points for one single day.
That person gets a brand new suit that
all people have to pay for it.
what suit?
Yeah.
From Hong Kong to make it?
No,
we're going to get david august to do
it.
Only the guy who makes suits for conor
mcgregor and me.
Yeah.
Okay.
That made sense from outside tom.
Really?
So we only make smalls.
Did he really just joking.
He's going to rap like 70 years.
No,
I don't think trump will get make seats
for putin.
Maybe we'll know kim jones guy by the
end of this.
Yeah,
like a soon we can make for this event,
but honestly it's just to only forgive
me,
but you kind of go on this until
probably may.
Yeah,
but that'd be.
That'd be fine because we'll have a
belt.
Yeah,
the winter.
Get to parade around birds.
Birds already got the belt sitting on a
shelf.
He's planning his little instagram
stories in front of the belt.
I can't wait
for sure.
Losing us.
Listen man,
you got a lot of resolve.
I saw how you manned up for the fucking
yoga challenge.
You might man up.
By the way.
I'm doing the yoga challenge too.
I'm doing both things.
You burst up doing yoga?
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
I'm going to do 15 hot yoga classes as
well.
Wow.
I'm going hard.
I'm trying to cut bert.
I'm trying to match job.
Five years.
Yeah.
The last time you worked at was probably
when we did jujitsu together.
Yeah,
probably I'd say 10,
10,
12 years.
I want to be like a day that hotel gym
for like 30 minutes.
One.
FIve years ago.
I burn.
I want joe to recognize the mickey
mantle gene.
That's bullshit.
Listen,
burst apart.
The marathon.
You should have already recognized.
Yeah,
I recognize that.
I want them to fall apart.
Trying to keep up though.
Has mickey mantle doing now?
He's not good.
He's not.
I just did all my measurements.
My priest sober october at measurements.
Not good already.
What do you weigh right now?
Mickey mantle.
He's dead.
That guy's dead.
Two 46.
40 eight.
Belly 44.
Waste 40 or belly?
No.
Belly 48.
Waste 44.
And then cabs and biceps or 16?
18.
What were you at the end of the weight
loss challenge?
Uh,
to 20 to 22 maybe.
Wow.
I was 2:16
at the end of october.
October last year.
Wow.
Yeah.
I'm going back.
I'm getting back.
I'm getting back to you.
I'm telling you right now.
I have motivation.
I'm what?
That belt.
I want that belt and I don't.
I'm not gonnA pay for anything I want
and I'm.
I want to see the look on your face when
you're like,
when you look at some of my numbers and
what the fuck is he doing?
He,
he's,
he's cheating.
He's cheating.
He's putting it on his dog.
Good luck with that in mind.
This is my wheelhouse,
motherfucker.
My wheelhouse.
I'm excited.
I'm so excited.
This is not my wheelhouse.
Oh,
I'm so excited.
Do they can get $500 a day?
I want to see if I can hit $500 a day.
Every day.
I'm just going to do different things
every day and I'm going to power.
Fuck.
I'm going to wear it like fuck.
I'm going to be.
This is the tortoise and the hare.
I'm just going to try the tortoise my
way through this month.
Yeah.
One hundred minutes at at a hundred
percent of maximum heart rate is 400
points,
right?
Is that what it is?
Okay.
Is that a word for a minute?
I don't know,
but I shit pegged.
I was at 97 percent for a half an hour.
I'm going to get none of that.
You are.
Just do it.
Try.
I'll this guy go fucking crazy.
Sorry.
Tiered punishment.
one event we all can agree on.
Correct.
Every single day,
most points suit and we can add
humiliation per like meaning like if we
come up with something during the month
that we all think is hilarious,
texted to each other,
we put it out on social media and we
hold ourselves to that too.
I don't think it's gonna.
Be epic from actor to do this and then
have nine months later because there'll
be a belt.
If burt winds will never hear the end of
it.
The belt will be on the shelf in front
of every fucking instagram video.
He makes like,
hey,
you guys might know me.
I'm burnt crusher still october champion
or left.
I like to call it sober october.
That's going to be his mo.
My motivation is all murder and death
and his motivation is all just going to
be like instagram stories.
Why are you scared of begging for money?
I'm not.
I'd be amazing at that already is.
I remember I barked at the boston comedy
club.
That's my.
That's my wheel house was talking to
strangers.
You know that.
It's true.
Why will you not do it?
I would do it in a heartbeat.
I would do that for a video.
I just do it for.
I don't care about begging for money.
I don't think he finds it enticing.
Oh,
right.
Yeah,
I get it.
Okay,
well,
we'll figure it out.
We'll figure the tiered structure will
make it to the second place.
Doesn't play as much as third place.
That doesn't pay as much.
Fortunately the way we can be joe rogan
that.
Would that be possible?
I'm definitely going to that by the way.
I just made eye contact with me and I
averted my eyes.
He looked at me like,
are you fucking serious?
I'm so excited about that.
This joke,
I don't believe in a lap.
Probably two of us,
maybe three to double our points.
I might take the whole month off comedy
on my workout day and night.
I might just want to.
I want to see what my body can do.
I might just go really crazy.
See what happens.
I got a lot of machines here too.
I'm the only one of us that has a full
gym.
Yeah,
you can come over here anytime you like.
Fella.
Are you talking about you can do.
yeah,
you could use my gym.
Fuck you.
I don't know how to use half those.
Misses a workout with you.
Taking my treadmill and dropping it off
here.
Fun to work workouts greater.
We can make videos.
All right,
let's do that.
Is that like a butter churner that you
can use?
Butter.
Churner.
we're going to get either way when it's
over.
We're getting fucked up.
So are you going to be around at all?
Anytime in november,
November 5th.
He said fifth,
sixth,
fifth or sixth?
He said I think fifth worker.
One.
I'm the third,
fourth,
fifth,
seventh and ninth.
But yeah,
whatever that was.
Which one works for everybody?
I think we all texted.
It's either the fifth or the sixth.
Fifth works better for tommy.
Okay.
That's.
That works for me man.
The fifth is perfect.
Fifth or the sixth?
Either one.
Oh no,
the sixth.
I've got work I got to show.
I have to do the six at night at 5:00.
There's a television show I got to do,
but I can do the fifth.
I think the fifth.
The fifth work better for dominick.
All right,
we'll do the fifth.
So the fifth will get fucking plowed.
We're going to bring in a.
Uh,
I'm going to get a keg rater.
Ooh.
Yeah.
We'll get a kegs.
Tito's.
Oh,
what do you need?
Ari for?
The fifth will get it in advance.
You like whiskey?
I love whiskey.
Pappy van winkle.
What's your favorite bourbon?
Text me.
Your favorite bourbon will get a fucking
caSe of it.
Uber drivers who can't.
Who can't do the fifth?
No,
tom.
I know tom.
Ken.
Ken works better for everyone.
Is everybody so sober?
October the fifth will be the
celebration day and then the day where
a.
Hopefully.
Yeah.
So when he flies back,
we'll get them fucked up as soon as he
lands.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is going to be awesome.
All right.
Like I waS trying to plug this and
there's not an email.
I'm sure they will.
I'm going to go charge mine right now
and then go put it in another workout.
They'll email you and me immediately and
if you need it was they got the message
and that was it?
No.
Did you send it to the support?
The email that I just sat in a text
message?
Yeah.
That's what was on the thing.
They didn't say.
Well they'll,
they'll send them to you quickly.
Um,
when they're going to hear about this.
First of all they're gonna hear about
this and they're probably gonna email
you quicker.
Um,
but if you have any ideas about the
design of the belt,
feel free to chime in there too because
we got an order that soon because it
takes like three to four weeks.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I think it'd be cool to have each of our
faceS as one of the side things with
our,
with our thing that is hard.
It's like you have a joint in your
mouth.
I have a tito's and my face already has
dick in his mouth and tom is a piece of
cake.
We'll figure it out.
Alright.
Love you.
Nice
crazy car.
So fucking excited for this.
It's going to be fun.
Dude.
I need these things in my life for some
reason I don't like.
I'm not,
I can't motivate unless I have like a
goal.
It's serious motivation.
You know?
What else this,
you know,
I was a skeptical
when I first thought about this,
but then in using the app while you're
using the app,
it's showing you your actual numbers
while you're doing it and when you're,
when you're,
when you're in the middle of it,
like you're seeing the actual numbers
take place.
Really?
Yeah.
My friend request.
I didn't know if I got it.
I know novick notifications on.
I just questioned you and tom.
Okay.
I'll,
I'll go.
What should we accept?
Other people should know?
Just the three of us.
Four of us want to live your life like
that.
I don't.
I thought it kind of is going to be fun.
It's going to be really going to be a
good one.
I wonder how much weight we are going to
lose.
I'm like one 97 [inaudible] 98 right
now.
I think I'm going to get down below one
90,
do body measurements because I think
that's like I did chest across the
nipples,
belly across the belly button,
waste and then biceps,
calves and thighs.
I'll tell you all my exact measurements
right now.
I think.
I just think it was accurate.
My blood pressure today was my doctor
calling about my blood pressure today to
figure out jesus will know because when
I do sober october go so low.
Is that bad?
No,
it's good,
but I'm on medication.
He wants to kind of watch my medication
so that if I.
What do you want?
Losartan and a or some another thing.
Jesus on that shit because I have high
blood pressure.
one 2,995.
Was it today,
but is that a natural thing that you
have?
High blood pressure is because of
drinking.
I think it's probably lifestyle induced
and things from being overweight and
probably from drinking but some bad
thing yet.
But they got you on pills?
Yeah,
but I not good.
You have.
It's better than a stroke.
Like I think me being proactive and
getting encino cardiologist these past
five years has been the best thing that
ever happened to me because there are
significant side effects to a lot of
those things.
Really?
Yeah.
You gotta look into that stuff.
I'd like to get off the pills all
together.
I'd like to get down.
I would like to.
I mean we talked about it jokingly,
but I'd like to get below two.
Oh five.
You can do that and keep it there.
Listen man.
When you got to to 20 or you get two to
16.
You said that she ended sober october.
Why?
What's to stop you from losing 11 more
pounds.
You can do that.
You think about what fighters do.
How about my friend cam hanes,
when he was getting down to run 240
miles,
he wanted to get down to 169 or below.
So you know what he did?
He ate 2000 calories,
burned off three.
Just kept doing it every day.
Send 10 people say they can't lose
weight.
I go,
oh,
you can.
You just got to be willing to do with
the people that actually lose weight
too.
If you're hungry all the time,
losing weight,
it's hard.
[inaudible],
I don't have what?
How I lose weight is not the healthy
way.
You crash.
I go,
fuck it.
Let's drop calories below a thousand.
RIght?
Bro.
Can't do that because we actually
discussed this on a podcast very
recently.
The problem is your metabolism crashes
as well and your body goes into this
famine mode and he wants to protect
calories,
so anything you do eat,
you gain back much quicker and then it's
far more difficult for you to lose again
because your body has a mechanism in
place to protect because your body
thinks it's,
you know,
we have to hold onto these calories.
It slows You down.
You're,
we're talking like one of the guys,
layne norton who's a,
uh,
he was involved in bodybuilding and he
was saying that his blinking was slower.
He was blinking slower because it's
shredding.
Getting down to like low body weight.
Yeah.
His metabolism crashed so hard that he
was literally blinking and thinking
slower and thinking is for you.
For comics,
terrible to be thinking slower when
you're on stage as the last thing you
want,
you know,
if you just work out like a fucking
maniac and eat healthy,
just cut out the sugar and the fat and
all the bullshit your body will slim
down was just going to go clean.
I heard of,
I had a nutritionist talk me through how
they eat,
what they say.
Uh,
well the thing that.
Here's the thing I always had a problem
with.
She was like,
you need to eat before you work out.
You need a little bit about meal,
but you need some energy for your
workout.
You don't necessarily have fast cardio
all the time.
I thought,
well that's what I've been doing the 16
hour fast.
She might be old school,
but if there's a lot of people that are
nutrition and the science behind
athletic performance has changed so much
over the last five,
10 Years.
This not,
you know,
just talking to some random nutritionist
might not be the best person to talk to.
They might not be.
I don't,
I don't want to say because I don't know
her,
but she might not be on the ball.
She,
I,
I just,
I feel like I had so much information.
Especially when you listen to this
podcast,
you get so much information.
Zach bitters,
like you got to go fatty meats and then
and then and then you hear Jordan
peterson's daughter saying that all
these people and then you go,
oh no,
very specific situation.
She hAs severe autoimmune immune issues,
severe.
She's most likely,
according to other nutritionist that
I've talked to,
she's probably got some gut bacteria
issue that she needs to get her gut
biome sorted out.
It's all so above my pay grade,
quite honestly.
I mean I get interested in this stuff
and I talk about and there's some things
that I could say with certain amount of
certainty,
but not really what you should and
shouldn't do in terms of each individual
person in their diet.
I would say if I was you,
what I would get down to is I would say
definitely start eating a lot of
vegetables.
There's a.
That's pretty much universal.
Everybody agrees except these crazy
carnivore people,
but I think their situation is like
either an elimination diet or a calorie
restricted diet,
which is not really the best for
performance,
I don't think for the kind of shit
you're trying to do.
Yeah.
I think broccoli,
kale,
spinach,
all that stuff,
sauteed,
all that stuff's fantastic for you.
Then on top of that mean obviously I eat
red meat.
I'm a big fan of red meat.
I think you should eat just like very
nutrient dense meet and I think you
should take multivitamins just to cover
all your bases.
You know,
there's a bunch of like really good
green supplements that you can add to
water or you know,
little packets you could take out your
calories.
No.
So you just eat until you're full.
Yeah.
Really?
How many calorIes do you think you need
a day?
I really don't know.
If you had to guess what's elc?
Elc is pretty lean.
Yeah.
It's pretty lean and you looks like
you're eating maybe eight ounces elk.
I probably eat a pound of that a day for
sure.
At least.
Yeah.
I mean,
I shoot when you're 400 pounds of meat.
I have some for you if you want.
I definitely do.
I got a bunch of sausage,
elk sausage.
Just sensational.
Really love it.
You'll love it.
A ton of it,
man.
I'm definitely up for that.
Yeah.
Okay.
I've got a bunch in the back.
I got these freezer bags too.
We can take it home with um,
well I would say just cut out the sugar
and the bread and the pasta and if you
just do that you'll lose a ton of
weight.
You lose a ton of weight.
Just doing that.
I'm in.
This one's going to be fucking awesome.
Yeah man.
Just vegetables.
Just eat a,
you know,
get yourself a fucking big bowl of
broccolini and cook it with butter and
olive oil and put garlic salt on it.
It's healthy.
It feels good when you eat it,
your body responds weLl to it.
You know,
just only good nutrients meant and just
realize you're going to have to get a
lot of rest and you're going out to
drink a shit ton of water because you're
going to be keeping up with some
terrifying numbers were going hard this
month per days,
man.
Thirty one days.
Yeah,
the end.
Ben.
Oof.
I'm going to fucking look a megan jack
shredded.
You're going to be like skinny bert like
from that photo and maybe maybe I'll do
trt to,
to view when do you know how you should
do trt?
Would you ever get your hormones tested
but tested?
Should get them tested,
is to find out where you're at.
It'll help everything.
Helps your immune system.
Helps your energy levels really helps
your concentration.
Yeah.
It's literally enhancing place.
You can get t dot.
Well you don't.
You got to do it.
Look at that picture.
Yeah,
that's my 40th birthday,
my 40th birthday.
Slender face.
See right there.
You are like five pounds from being
shredded.
If you have right there and you lost
five pounds,
you'd have a six pack that I did the
cus.
I lost that weight in 19 days.
Wow.
See,
the problem is when you do that,
the yo yo,
your crap.
Why is a picture of me shirtless?
Right under burt's picture.
That's me when I was like 26.
Oh my god,
it's me on newsradio 20,
27 sexy pitch.
Um,
what?
So yeah,
the problem is losing the,
losing the weight,
like a crash.
The problem with the crash is see if you
lose the weight over the month because
you're just burning it off like a
madman,
but you're eating a lot.
Your body's not going to be in famine
mode.
Your body is going to be more efficient.
It's going to need more cows and you
definitely should lift weights.
That's one thing you should do over
this.
And lifting weights will also add to
this I,
my,
my plan is lifting weights,
kickboxing,
running hills,
yoga,
and then Various cardio machines from
the versa climber to the rower,
to the echo bike.
I'm going to rotate them all so I can
keep doing all of them so I can do
different ones.
I got the rower
in my house,
I got the assault air fitness trainer.
Don't deny yourself any food though.
Just fucking pound food,
pound food all the time because you're
just going to be.
YOu're going to be so hungry.
All right.
I think,
yeah,
if I.
If I do,
if I figured if I do two days and then
and just go,
I know what I got to get a day.
Yeah.
It just keep going.
Yeah,
it's going to be great for all of us.
It Was.
I was thinking about that today when I
was a.
When I was working on,
I was like,
wow,
this is a very.
When you looking at the numbers on that
thing,
it's very motivational.
You know?
It's funny,
when before when I was in college,
I ran and what was really fun,
the stuff these rudders journals is to
get done your run and write them in
tracking your fitness.
Tracking your workout is.
It's really fun to look at numbers and
stack up.
It's almost like it feels like some,
like almost like a hoarder's vibe or
like an ocd vibe.
Yeah,
it's definitely better.
Like when it's on this app than it is if
you just know you're worked out.
Yeah.
I used to.
When I used to,
when fitbit first came out,
I used to get.
I had to get to 12,000
steps every day and I would,
I would land from a flight,
get up to my hotel room,
open a bottle of wine and just start
dancing.
Fucking weird as fuck.
Like if someone came and complained,
I,
they would think I was on meth.
Yeah,
it's,
it feels good.
It feels good to set goals I might have,
but I always tell people like one of the
best ways to get things done is to write
things down.
It is,
it's such a huge motivating factor.
Like you have a list of shit that you
have to do today and check those bitches
off and then at the end of the day you
feel good.
Like you go to bed,
you feel good.
I checked off all those things on my
list.
I'm better now.
I feel better than I was before.
Yeah.
My wife's a big list maker.
Huge.
When you make a list,
it really does organize your day like I
will when I was shooting,
shooting the promo thing for my tour
next week and I shot at this weekend in
san jose and uh,
and I was like,
I had all these different things I
needed to do and my wife's like,
make a fucking list.
And I went,
oh yeah,
yeah.
So I wrote down all the shots I needed
that I'd feel like I didn't feel like I
didn't get the night before and then
just banged it out and I was like,
wow,
that was fucking easy as shit.
Yeah,
it's so much better than like trying to
remember what else,
what else do I need to do?
And then like half ass in it.
You knoW what you did.
That's very impressive.
You came up with a new hour pretty
fucking quick.
Like how long did it take you to come up
with a new hour?
Uh,
I came up with it.
I've,
I don't know,
maybe like a february,
march,
april,
may,
june,
six months.
What did you do to ramp up your writing?
A super aware.
So my biggest thing for me,
which I think helped me back,
and I've,
I've talked about this a lot,
maybe a lot,
but when you were in production brain,
you didn't have room for comedy brain.
Like when I was making a tv show I never
did another room for comedy and so I
might be obsessed with football so there
might be something wrong with me,
but when I'm in comedy brain and which
is when I'm.
When I'm doing a special,
it's focused on only that material,
like only the material.
But when I docked on the special I just
went up and was like,
here.
It was the most enjoyable time in my
life.
It's like everything was a bit just
walking around.
I was looking for things and just being
inspired by the littlest thing even to
this day,
but it's part of the reason I like to go
over to New York and do podcasts and
fuck around.
I was on anthony humanist podcasts.
I came up with two bits in the moment
that I was like,
do those,
those are going to new environment and
new feeling your brain firing and done.
Not denying myself the opportunity of a
bit because a bit is silly or goofy or
hacky in my head.
I go,
that's okay,
let's keep working that.
And so,
um,
I have right now I have like 55 minutes
that I'm,
that I feel is really solid,
but the goal now sort of like we were
talking to tom was talking about
untangling it is like weaving it in.
So that one that follows the other one.
So right now I'm playing with these
bits,
putting them in different places,
trying to figure out what could follow a
bit.
That's the funnest part also.
Right.
And then once I do that and once I have
no what I'm doing,
my next vessel,
that's what it almost becomes less fun
for me.
It's like I don't want to go to the
store because I don't want to write new
bits,
but like in this salad days or when
you're just all writing,
I loved that shit.
Just going up on stage and going in la
and be like,
I bought a gun and just go and just
feeling the energy and being like,
oh,
I'm in,
I'm in it.
I don't know where this is going.
I could lose them.
Right,
right.
So I wouldn't buy numbing,
joking.
I went and bought a gun because I
thought it wouldn't be a good bit when I
went and said,
did you say that on stage?
No,
yoU should,
but that should be part of the bet.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
fucking done.
I bought a gun because they thought it'd
be a good bet.
I was driving out in burbank and I was
like,
oh,
this gun talk.
And I was like,
I don't have any gun material.
Was like I should buy a gun.
And I was like,
have a real gun nut on your podcast to
talk to you about guns.
I should,
you know,
she can't get on a colion noir either.
That guy follow that guy on youtube.
He was on my podcast.
Good guy.
Yeah,
he's great.
Yeah.
Was.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Fucking I'm going to.
I'm going to be like the progressive guy
that makes it seem like there's
something wrong that you're pointing it
out.
Yes.
He happens to be an african american.
No,
but in that culture you have to bring it
up in that culture that is so
interesting that they.
It's almost like a.
I feel like when he had a mr mike on
magic.
Mike,
not magic mike.
Killer killer mike on.
It was really cool to hear this through
mike magic.
Mike was here,
they're white guy.
Mike.
It was cool to hear their perspective on
it,
you know,
Because culturally you always see a
company,
the nra come from this like whIte
redneck thing.
No,
he's.
well,
you know,
he makes real good points.
I mean,
he wasn't a lawyer.
He was a lawyer.
Right?
I'm pretty sure it was like he was.
Yeah.
But he makes really good points in terms
of like a personal safety and
responsibility.
The thing about like,
people equate nra with mass shootings
and all kinds of other crazy shit,
which is not really totally fair because
no nra member has ever committed a mass
shooting.
you know,
whenever something happens,
they think,
oh,
this is all because these people want
the other people that have access to
these kinds of guns.
The real connection,
as always an ad nauseum.
I've talked about this too much,
is psychotropic drugs.
Those people are almost all on some sort
of psych medicine.
All of them.
Yeah.
The is a ca.
Is it causation or correlation?
That's the problem.
Is the psychotropic drugs cause causing
them to do this or are they on
psychotropic drugs because they're crazy
and they shouldn't haVe a gun anyway and
it should be more difficult.
I'm I'm 100 percent.
I'm in believed that you should test
people and that there should be some
sort of standards in terms of mental
health in terms of Whether or not you've
committed assault,
whether or not like those kinds of
things,
whether or not you have a history of
mental illness,
lashing out or violent outbursts.
Yeah.
Those kind of people shouldn't have guns
that the kind of people that think
everybody shouLd have access to a gun,
I think that's a little irresponsible,
but the kind of people that think no one
should have a gun,
I think that's irresponsible to scratch
crazy talk.
I mean,
it's not going to happen in our country.
No,
not in this one.
but you should haVe him on men or or
there's other gun nuts.
I could turn you onto my friend.
Justin's legit gun nut.
Just met him just in college.
He's been on my podcast for.
He's a legiT giant.
He's like seven feet tall,
but he's a real gun nut.
He's.
He lives in vegas.
He has so many guns.
Doesn't know how many guns.
Yes.
Well,
no,
no.
Stay.
I'm thinking of the.
The,
the fighter.
Frank mir is a big gun guy.
Giant gun guy.
Frank mir strapped everywhere.
He goes.
He's got like one in his ankle.
One up his ass.
Frank,
here's a really interesting guy.
Smart dude.
He did my this.
There's something about cage fighters
were there.
Is there,
is there a very direct and they say what
they mean and they mean what they say.
Tate was the first person that I ever
ran into that was like that.
He texted me and I didn't text back and
he texted again and then he texted,
hey man,
I'm starting to get feelings about this.
Text me back.
And then I was like,
well yeah,
frank meir said he came to my podcast,
we had a cigar while we're doing the
podcast and he's just like,
I'm such and maybe I'm such in this
weird bullshit hollywood world where
people don't mean what they say that I,
I'm used to that.
And he goes,
uh,
that was a really great cigar.
We should do this.
We should have another one.
I Was like,
okay.
And he's like,
well,
what are you doing it like eight
tonight?
And I was like,
I'm here.
And he was like,
I'm going to do a podcast so I have
another cigar.
I was like,
okay.
I sure I didn't think I'd ever seen him
again.
He showed back up at 7:55.
He was like,
you ready for that car?
And we went in my back yard.
We spoke to another cigar,
just talked.
It was like he fucked.
okay.
It's fine.
It's being sincere as an oddity.
Yeah.
This is the world of acting.
That's what it is.
You around this world of auditions and
actors and producers and exactly this
strange land we live in,
man,
this right here.
This shit happens in other places,
but it just is very prevalent here.
Like where people just aren't genuine
and they're not honest.
You put this like
people just lick their finger and stick
it out in the wind trying to figure out
which way the wind's blowing and that's
the way they go.
Like because everybody just wants
everybody to like them out here.
Everyone's auditioning for things.
It's just such a strange place,
man.
I saw my buddy eddie is a like a man,
you know the cuban from Florida.
Bill fist fight his fucking chair.
You know,
just a regular guy.
That means maxwell.
Man.
He came out the first time he came out,
there was a comic,
I won't say his name,
who was holding court at the hollywood
improv and he was making fun of me like
as the joke,
everyone was laughing and I was laughing
and my buddy eddie just kind of looked
sideways and we got in the car and he
goes,
why why'd you let that happen?
I go,
he's,
he's super famous.
I mean,
you know,
it's like whatever.
He was not man,
now he's,
he's smaller than you.
Why don't you just fucking knock them
out?
And I go,
that's not how it works out here.
He goes,
yeah,
it is.
It is.
It does let them say that shit to me.
That's how it works.
I go,
no,
I understand.
Yeah.
I was just knocking about and he was
like,
dude,
I don't like that disrespectful shit.
I was like,
well,
it's different out here at.
He goes,
no,
it's not your,
it's different cause you're letting it
be different.
Well,
it depends on how close you are with the
guy because if you're really good
close with the guy and he's saying funny
things and you think they're funny and
you laughing sincerely,
like we bust on each other all the time.
Yeah.
But it's not disrespectful.
It's just hilarious.
It's just,
I think it's,
I think everyone knows that we're all
close friends and that's our,
it's our language.
But there are people who are not your
close friends who was like,
you look at bird over there with blah
blah,
and then they'll start fucking with you.
And nick gets a little slippery and
grow.
It's a.
especially,
there's,
there's uh,
it's narcissism.
It's guys who Built it.
They just,
they think they'll alfia yeah.
And it's funny.
I,
I definitely have changed from that.
When you know,
when you're young and you're hungry in
this business and you want to succeed,
you don't want to tell a famous guy that
might be able to give you work him and
don't talk to me like that because then
you almost like blackball yourself.
Right?
Well,
you've had some bad experiences and we
don't need to mention any names that you
had some bad experiences with a
particular comedian that was like that
where,
you know,
we've talked about it.
There's,
there's mental mentally ill people that
are in this business too,
you know,
there's that.
It's tough.
Yeah.
I feel like,
uh,
I feel like sometimes I draw them in.
It's taught to stand up.
Nice.
Yeah.
And I,
and I,
and I'm,
I,
I'll say this about myself,
but I'm very creative and I like to fuck
around.
I like to,
you know,
and I think some people see that as a
weakness.
I,
I'm,
there's someone that I'm told you
privately that stole from me,
that was a friend separate and it,
I,
man,
that fucking makes me angry because I
go,
I remember when it happened and I had
already dealt with something else that
was similar to that.
I remember I was at my wife's lake house
when someone texted me and said,
hey man,
did you give that job to that person?
And I was like,
no man,
it pulled this fucking thing in my.
In my head.
That was like,
I remember thinking,
did you,
do you think I'm weak?
Do you think I won't say anything.
Do you think?
Do you think that you can do that to me?
right.
And,
and I didn't say anything.
I didn't say anything because I learned
the first time around that it really
almost like all these that come out
about sexual assault.
It doesn't,
it doesn't benefit you to coMe out and
say that someone stole joke from you.
You just equate still.
I know,
but no,
but it's coming.
It's that coming forward thing where
when you look at these women and said
there's no benefit and go,
people go,
oh bitches.
I go,
no,
theY don't.
There's not a lot of benefit to go and
say you've been raped because now you've
got to fucking.
That's what you're defined as and,
and you.
And You've got to defend yourself from
something you didn't do to yourself.
and so when you get stolen from them,
obviously that is a stretch of an
equivalent person.
But to come out and defend yourself,
people do start attackIng.
You go,
why would you even say anything to?
You're just,
you're just jealous.
Pull yourself out on a limb.
If you're talking about someone taking
something like a joke for me too,
because you have.
You have to hope that people side with
you.
So like say if some famous person steal
something from you,
you have to hope when you come out that,
that they're not a bunch of people going
to jump on his side and attacked you,
which is totally possible.
And if tHey do then you're fucked and
you're out on a limb.
Dude,
I went through,
I went through and I screen grabbed
everything.
That was proof.
unequivocably screen grabbed everything.
Fuck them.
Yeah,
I got everything.
Yeah.
Oh no.
said I'll never do anything with it.
But you know what man?
The good lesson is now that person you
Could write off forever.
It's like,
what was the goodfellas?
What was it?
What was the movie like?
You got off light.
Like now you know the for $20 or $200,
whatever it is.
Now that person never has talked to you
again.
Yeah,
he good.
You know you sometimes it's sometimes
when someone does something like that,
you're like,
okay,
now I can write you off
and in and write them off in a very
interesting way as a comic to know,
oh,
you never had it.
You never will.
You don't got what I have.
I can make more of that shit.
That's what I do for a living.
Oh,
you,
oh my god.
So when you really don't have any
material and you don't know how to
write,
you don't know how to write new
material.
Oh,
shut the fuck up.
So that's what you can't do.
Oh,
suck a dick.
There's two.
There's two different types of mindsets.
The type of mindset where someone like
steals someone else's ideas and tries to
pass them off as their own is kind of
the opposite mindset as to someone who's
creative.
Because when you're creative,
you're thinking about a bit and you're
not thinking about yourself and how the
bid is going to work for you and how
it's going to kill when you get out
there,
but when you're stealing,
if something like say if you have a bit
about lollipops and I go,
oh,
I wish that was my bit.
I'm going to steal that lollipop bit,
that pitt's going to kill,
and then I do that lollipop it and it
crushes and I call.
I feel so good when I do that lollipop
pit,
they get addicted to it.
That's one of the things about people
that get called out for bits and they
say,
I'm not going to do it anymore,
and then I already did that bit at the
laugh factory here because they get
addicted to get addicted to the
reaction.
That bit gets.
See there,
you're addicted to coming up with new
stuff like an I am and the people that
are trying to be creative.
What you're trying to do is you have.
You're trying to like summon
these ideas out of the ether.
You're trying to pull them out of the
air and then once you have them like,
okay,
I got it in a bottle,
now I've got to add things to it.
I've got to bring it alive.
I gotta fucking frankenstein and it's
alive,
and then one day,
months and months later you trot that
bid out of the improvident fucking
crushes and that is one of the most
amazing feelings.
Like someone like sam tripoli or bill
burke come up and go,
dude,
I love that.
And just go like,
it's working.
I got it.
It's pumping.
We all.
We all love that about each other too.
I love when someone's got a new bit.
I think it was that new.
What has that been like?
Oh dude,
your last hour that comes out tonIght at
midnight.
I remember watching you run it in the or
at the.
At its infancy probably like eight
months ago.
Right when I was getting ready to in
february when I was getting ready to
tape my special,
I saw you doing yours and I was like,
oh shit.
Is this your new material?
And you're like,
yeah,
I'm getting ready to film and you know,
a couple of months.
And I was like,
oh,
like dude,
that's the greatest feeling when you sit
as a comic in the back and you watch
your friends just fucking murderer.
It's inspires you with shit you haven't
heard.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
that's the best.
But people that still will never get
that.
They will never get it.
They're missing that.
The,
it's sad.
It's a sad thing because they're always
going to have to live this weird lie.
You know,
he does weird lie of creativity because
creativity is so slippery and you can't
be thinking about yourself.
That's not what it's about.
It's the opposite about that.
It's all about the idea.
It's all about how it gets to the
people.
It's all about how it works.
Like you have to like take yourself
literally out of the equation.
But the people still there,
it's all about them.
It's all about them getting a good
feeling,
doing someone else's bit.
And I really think that that is.
There's this weird balance to the world
and I think when when you do that,
I think it takes away from your ability
to do the other thing takes away from
your ability to be creative.
I would almost argue I'm the exact
opposite.
When it gets up and running and
murderous.
I almost feel like I'm lying to the
audience.
Like I'm cheating going,
going like,
you know,
it works.
I've been doing it too long.
I have a hard time doing sets of the
store when I'm.
When I got my hour ready,
I go,
what am I doing going there for?
I'm going to.
I'm still in a spot from someone who
couldn't use it and I'm just going up
with shit that works.
Like,
oh,
come on bert.
Yeah,
but you're giving the audience a good
time and you're keeping everything
sharp.
That's the other thing,
like once a bit is done,
it's you can't just leave it alone
because like if I had to today go up and
do my bruce jenner bit,
wouldn't be able to do it.
I don't know how to do it.
Haven't done it in two years.
I literally wouldn't be able to do it is
one of my best bits ever and I wouldn't.
I wouldn't know where to start.
I would have to go back,
listen to it,
and then I would have to go do it a
bunch of times.
It's get it polished.
It's really fun though.
When someone calls out a joke that you
haven't told in years and you're like,
I did it this past week.
I do.
I do an hour,
25 minutes,
show our 20th show where I do my new
hour and then at the end of whatever
bits want to hear,
I'll tell
you that's nice and a two man show.
So you have someone do 15 minutes and I
do the rest and that way I feel like
people definitely want to hear flying
dildos are the machine or someone called
out a mexican kid in the elevator and I
was like,
whoa,
I haven't done that since my first
special comments.
I do it.
I didn't.
And so I started doing it and I was
like,
and I was,
and I just kinda,
you're my muscle memory goes back in and
then you're like,
and you're so much better of a comedian
now that the things that you would have
never said back then,
she didn't know how to do it.
You just start adding ad libs in and it
just kills.
And you're like,
shit man.
I had a guy come on stage once.
He asked me to do a bit.
I go,
I don't remember how to do a bed.
He goes,
I do.
I go,
get up,
you're a bitch.
That stage.
And I had him kind of do the bed.
I go,
yeah,
I remember that part.
Okay,
okay.
You know,
I saw some guy on instagram,
uh,
did he goes,
he was doing my machine bit as a joke,
like he's an open mic or is this maybe
it's 10 time on stage or whatever.
And his friends,
I guess her fans.
And he was like,
when I was 22 I got involved with the
restroom,
my machine,
or with the russian mafia,
here's how it happened.
And they all started laughing and he
goes,
I'm just kidding.
I ain't doing that shit.
But it made me giggle because he missed.
He misspoke.
It's not the way I say it.
I,
I got,
I got in a scuffle with the russian
mafia or something and it made me
giggle.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
It's weird
how people interpret your.
Like when you do something and then
people really like it and they take it
and they make a clip about it or
something,
or they add something to it or they.
One of the weirder things has been the
animated shit that people do.
Yeah.
You know,
she's just like,
you go.
You were talking about this the other
day that when you're in this room and
you're doing this podcast,
it just seems like you and me are
talking.
That's one of the reasons why it works,
or you and me and whoever else is here,
but the people that hear it,
you're the actual numbers that you're
dealing with.
You're dealing with millions of people
like that doesn't seem to register in
your head.
And then you'll see these clips and you
see like these memes and you'll see like
these videos and ucf,
these animated shorts and you see people
do impressions of you and you're like,
wait,
what?
What the fuck is that?
It takes.
And then You'll see people get tattoos
of your face on their ass or something
like that.
Like on your calf.
They get you smiling,
your beard and you're on theIr calf and
you're like,
what the fuck?
The machine,
it'll take.
Like I saw a dude who have that russian
tee-shirt tattooed on his body.
The one that you made with the machine
with russian language,
with you,
like looking off into space.
I was like,
whoa,
fucking
insane swearing.
It's insane.
Especially like,
I mean when I,
when I saw that joe rogan means road
yogan,
I was just use the guy's a wizard.
Whoever did that shit.
I had gotten done a show in oxnard and
my kids were in the other room.
My wife is a new one out with you and
you know,
I just,
it
stops talking shit that made me,
that made me giggle so hard.
I could not,
the ini just gotten high and I was in a
room by myself.
My famIly is in another room and I,
I was like,
dude,
I wish.
I hope this guy knows how much joy he
just gave me.
Like whatever I was thinking about,
you know,
like my sat or whatever.
I'm dying fucking laughing.
I was like,
dude,
thank you man.
Well,
it's the amount of effort that it takes
to listen to so much audio that you can
have a conversation back and forth
between a dude and his self.
LIke,
you know,
how many videos that guy must have had
to listen to and how much editing he had
to do to do that too.
I want a fanboy out,
but I'm a huge fan and it cuts to you.
I was pissing myself.
I literally hit paul.
You know what?
Like when you get excited and you're
like,
I think you had sent it to me.
Maybe.
Maybe it's somewhat set.
Maybe tommy said it to me and I
immediately was too late,
but I wanted to text everyone and go,
I want everyone to see this.
And then when it cut,
by the way,
I'm already giggling some,
you know,
and then when it cuts to me as the main
ge chimp,
I fucking howling howling and I'm
excited.
Chimp,
like,
oh jesus,
I'll rip your dick off.
Yeah,
no fucking.
And then when he just did the new one,
I got to go pick up my daughter,
uh,
when he just did the new one on me
drinking 30 to 35.
Yeah.
This pr firms,
that time warp it really is,
is,
it's a time warp.
When the fuck do you ever sit down and
talk to somebody for three hours?
So the best.
It's the best thing about these podcasts
is that you literally sit and catch up
and break balls and giggle,
come up with brilliant challenges due to
its changed me.
It's changed me as a person.
My,
my ability to communicate is so much.
I'm just so much better at it than I was
nine years ago when I first started
doing this.
You really are there.
I mean,
I,
I can say this as a fan,
I think anyone who listens,
I've been listening to podcasts.
I always listen to the podcast.
You've changed immeasurably in almost
the most renaissance way is like you
have conversations with people.
I wouldn't know what the fUck they even
do,
but there's still hints oF exaCtly who
you are.
You're very measured and what you say
and how you put out your ideas.
You listen,
you're willing to change.
I remember when you stopped saying
faggot,
I remember when you were like,
you know what,
I think I'm going to stop saying that.
Like in conversation.
I remember I was like,
oh,
that's a good idea.
Maybe I'll just stop to.
We were in the old desk squad,
uh,
east or west.
Was it?
Oh,
in pasadena.
Yeah.
Well the problem is,
it's a fun thing to say and you don't
mean it in a homophobic way.
It's stills fun to say I still let it
slip out every now and then.
Age,
like a fine wine.
It's a fun thing to say,
but the problem is the way it makes
other people feel.
It's not fun.
It's language should be about intent.
It should be about you're conveying your
intent through a sound.
Yeah,
but the problem is it's not working
correctly.
Like if,
if someone is hearing it on the other
end and it's making them angry and
you're like,
but no,
I'm silly.
I'm being silly about it.
I'm gonna silly faggot.
Like they're like,
no,
no.
You can't.
Like,
okay,
well it's not.
This is an ineffective use of sound to
convey my thoughts.
Yeah,
and is it worth it to piss people off?
You know,
is it worth it?
Like,
look what happened with tommy and the
word retard,
which he's not calling anyone that it's
not the,
the bid is about forbidden language and
he literally.
All he said in that bit was that you're
not allowed to use that word anyMore.
and in saying that there was massive
protests.
There's all these people freaking out
because they don't even want you to
utter the sound.
It's a real problem because that kind of
thinking is nonsense.
Like this to say that it can't be used
ever,
that you can't admit that it's a word,
like you cannot say it,
you cannot utter it,
but it's abracadabra,
that it's a magic word.
You can't even bring it up in
conversation.
Who had to understand that we are
changing.
So this word,
whatever the word is,
that you can't say it anymore because
remember they were trying to get rid of
bossy.
Do you remember bossing?
No.
Yeah,
yeah.
They were trying to say that bossy is a
sexist word.
You shouldn't use bossy.
They abandoned it,
but it's that point is that they'll,
they'll try to find something to be
offended by and they'll try to put
whatever that word is into this
forbidden category and then you can have
so many words in that category.
Then it's going to be crazy and then you
have noises that you can't make.
I think the real thing that's going to
change and I really think this is going
to happen,
is we're going to figure out a way to
bypass language is going to be weighted
to directly convey information to people
without language and it's going to
happen through some sort of technology
and elon musk was talking about it on
the podcast or something called neuro
link that he's working on that some sort
of a really revolutionary way to
increase bandwidth between you and ideas
and how ideas get to your head.
It's going to Be something that you were
and I think that's going to be like step
one and then you're going to be able to
do that from person to person.
And I think you know,
all this were so invasive now with
social media like it's so and cell
phones and electronics.
everything is in your life and people
are getting closer and closer to each
other.
And one of the Side effects is that of
that is that people now realize they can
hurt you so they can attack you easier.
And they go and they can tear things
down to can light things on fire because
they can,
not necessarily because it's a wise
thing or it's a measureD thing or it's a
really well thought out thing.
They're doing it just Because it's a new
thing that they can use.
Like you gave a chimp and ak 47 and they
just started shooting up the jungle.
I mean literally that is what a lot of
people were doing with social media,
but I think that is just a stage and
that eventually we're going to bypass
language.
I really do.
I really think that the thing it's going
to be like emojis,
that way they can communicate through
like a form of hieroglyphics almost.
This is a conversation that you need to
have a November 5th one.
I'm high.
We're going to be bang big drunk.
Fucked up November 5th.
I can't fucking wait.
let's wrap this up.
So,
uh,
we
kind of have a parameter.
We'll figure it out as we go along.
Got it written.
All right.
Here.
I'll take a picture and leave it here.
All right.
But I figured this is awesome.
This is awesome.
It's going to be awesome.
The belts going to be shit because we're
going to have that belt every year.
I can't fucking wait to get up.
Deluxe belt to fat leather brass.
Beautiful.
Alright,
your special tonight at midnight.
Midnight tonight.
Uh,
it's called a strange times.
Fucking amazing.
We live in.
I sold the material to store.
Thanks so brookside for you,
man.
I'm excited too.
Nervous to.
Bye everybody.